well this is gonna be like absolutely
insane if you guys do not know what is
going on just sit back and relax as it's
going to blow all of your minds as it
did when i first read the story like
this story here is something that is
extremely special to me i first started
reading it at probably you know like the
worst point in my short life that i've
had sob story i know like who actually
cares but there was a hitman involved so
it was an extreme level that most people
probably don't deal with anyways you
know enough of that i didn't know what i
wanted to do like kind of at this point
but if it wasn't for the utter enjoyment
and pure love that i felt while reading
this arc literally everything wouldn't
have turned out how it has so for me
being able to share this arc with you is
really special and i wouldn't have
dreamed a few years ago that i would
have been able to share one of the
greatest arcs and modern manga with you
all and like i'm being full on serious
when i say this is like one of the
greatest arcs in modern manga this is on
par with like the international
assassins arc from chainsaw man and like
it's better than a lot of the arcs that
i've ever watched so i don't really know
what to compare it to it's that freaking
good so i can't wait until hopefully
this next season that we get to see them
but anyway firstly previously on giga
akatami's acid trip visualized we had
the chosen one himself satoru gojo fall
into a deep sleep in which we were shown
through his dreams probably one of the
most damn high backstories of the recent
era side note though straight up gige
never misses with these arcs like i
don't know how he does it but it's just
goddamn beautiful other mangakas out
there spam and training arcs like mha
but giga dropping hate always anyways
anyways gojo was able to overcome the
powerhouse himself toji for shigeru and
his second match up however we did lose
the star plasma vessel which has some
extremely important effects that are
going to affect the modern day
throughout the later parts of this arc
here but you know rico would have
actually been able to survive this
incident if she was just using her
ultimate defense surfshark vpn and well
you guys know what surf shark vpn does
it secures your online activity and can
protect you from hackers data theft and
secure your online identity now honestly
up until recently i thought i'd be the
last person to use a vpn as i can always
kind of find the shows that i'm looking
for on specific websites if you know
what i mean but after the new zealand
border walls dropped and i escaped the
country with all my manga in hand for
the first time i soon realized that
those same websites can't even be
accessed from different places abroad i
was left utterly confused and in a
catatonic state unable to move or think
until they arrived surfshark vpn and
with a simple flick of the wrist i was
able to change my location right back to
my safe place where i know all the
websites i use work that wasn't even the
end i was so weeped up all of a sudden i
started learning formal japanese
straight from the japanese netflix page
so that next time i get a strike i can
formally address them with my new cool
second language and you guys can too by
easily downloading surfsharkvpn from the
link below or by chucking in my
beautiful code diavolo you get 83 off
and three yes three months free on top
of it and it doesn't even stop there no
matter where you are whether it be in
the house on the toilet the fridge
anything surfsharkvpn supports it all so
stop there stop watching go outside
touch some grass then come back in and
download surfshot vpn because if you
don't who knows what might happen to
your unprotected device and especially
your family's devices couldn't be me man
but anyway thank you to surfsharkvpn for
sponsoring this video so continuing on
october the 19th of 2018 gojo is asleep
when megami yuji and nobara arrive once
awoken and after a small greeting gojo
sends them to udahime's location there
she tells them that there are two moles
one of which is actually one of the
jujutsu higher-ups since they can't do
anything about that presently their main
target is whoever is feeding information
to that said higher up nobara asks if
the mole is someone from kyoto
surprising yuji as utahime prepares to
reveal to them who it is elsewhere
kasumi meets with mikamaru she tells him
that their notebooks are due today and
he replies that he is going to sleep
back at mikamaru's alleged hideout
udahime informs the tokyo first years
that it has to be kokichi due to the
process of elimination using puppet
manipulation to steal information
wouldn't be difficult for someone like
megamaru at the same time kikichi
prepares for his visitors however yuji
bursts down the door to the fake hideout
confirming to them that he's the mole at
his actual hideout kokichi meets with
mojito and ghetto okay you know quick
note waves so i'm going to call suede
ghetto or sudokito however you like to
say it just ghetto from now on so it
doesn't get confusing but just know it
ain't actually ghetto so it's easier for
me to call them just ghetto until i can
have that fair reveal on all of you
anyway anyway kokichi comments about how
he had thought that they had forgotten
about him but getty replies that they
would never do that since kikichi knows
the consequences of having a curse
restriction asmojito suggests that they
kill kakichi since they have all the
information they need ghetto tells him
that they have to heal kakichi first
before they can kill him due to the
terms of the binding vow between them
mojito begrudgingly uses his idol
transfiguration to heal kakichi giving
him a healthy body for the first time
mohito remarks that kikichi should show
some enthusiasm but he replies that that
comes after they settle their business
with no more words left to be said the
battle at the dam begins
kikichi calls an entire army of
mikamaru's to his side as his
confrontation with ghetto and mojito
escalates he enlarges his arm and
smashes the wave of mikamaru's aside
kokichi disappears in the confusion and
mojito figures that he run away without
any reason to kill them bored mojito
claims he's not in the mood for hunting
suddenly the underground leg collapses
forcing mojito to quickly escape
outdoors mohito looks at the giant lake
with an excited smile as ultimate
mikamaru mode absolute appears from
within its head doing final checkups
kikichi notices a curtain forming around
the area casted by ghetto he thinks that
he needs to escape the curtain and reach
gojo to let him know about shibuya
however the only way to do that would be
defeating mojito first knowing that he
won't stand much of a chance he still
doesn't plan on holding back and will
use all 17 years five minutes and six
days worth of cursed energy he's
accumulated to win he starts off by
sending an entire year's worth of cursed
energy into his ultimate mikamaru and
blasts mojito with his ultra cannon
destroying the dam and sending rubble
flying having dodged the initial blow
mohito knows these types of attacks
won't be effective and dives into the
water using a two-year charge of cursed
energy kikichi blasts the entire lake
with miracle cannon but despite his best
effort maheso leaps from the water to
radius strike at him kikichi believes
mojito was overlooking his offense so
now it's time to put his secret plan
into action mojito extends his arm and
grabs on to mikamar's head to accurately
deliver a cursed energy infused punch
which vigorously shakes the cockpit
inside kikichi inserts a small tube into
one of his side panels and activates a
curse technique charge the tip of
mikamaru's finger splits open to reveal
a small cannon which then instantly
fires a spiked projectile that stabs
into mojito as he's flying around
initially mojito doesn't see it as a
threat but suddenly his wing explodes
leaving him open to get smacked aside by
mikamaru mahato crashes through several
trees confused as to how his soul was
destroyed nikimaru then absolutely
pummels the ground forcing haito to fly
away and retreat kikichi notices mahito
reshaping himself to hide his injuries
making him feel more confident that he
might win even ghetto acknowledges that
kikichi is skilled and his strategies
are working against mojito kikichi then
uses an insane five-year charge called
pigeon viola to send five cannons of
cursed energy shooting at his opponents
mojito shape-shifts and tries to avoid
the beams but he's taken by surprise
when mika mario crushes them from above
the curse narrowly avoids getting hit
but mikumaro follows up with another
strike that seems maheso flying back
into the trees again confident that
he'll be able to achieve his dreams
kikichi activates another cursed
technique charge reshaping mkhimaru's
middle finger into a spike however the
big bad wolf activates his domain
expansion the self-embodiment of
perfection which is just like hell
acclaim and i honestly love the growth
of mojito's character throughout the
story dude thinks he's like perfection
but he's the absolute like opposite of
everything he thinks it's so good idol
transfiguration automatically hits and
forces ultimate mikamaru to collapse
appearing to signal kokichi's demise
confident in his automatic win strategy
mojito turns his back to the giant
cursed corpse and states kikichi
shouldn't put so much faith into a
strategy suddenly mikamaru gets back up
and stabs the spike on his middle finger
through mojito's back it is explained
that the cursed technique tubes contain
simple domains the domain for the weak
invented in the heian era out of the
four tubes that contained it the first
failed the second protected the cockpit
from the domain and the third appears to
have finished mojito off for good as his
body seemingly explodes after being
stabbed mikamaru roars and turns his
weapon towards ghetto ready to use his
remaining nine years to finish him off
however the cockpit abruptly explodes
from the impact of mojito's enlarged
fist horrified kikichi looks through the
broken window to see mojito's deranged
smile
kikichi takes his last technique tube
and desperately rushes towards mojito
and little team to stab him yet just as
the two are about to touch and skips
away to kikichi recalling talking with
kasumi about getting to know one another
better she made a promise to come see
him but sadly mojito is ensured that
that will never happen mikamaru
collapses for good with its pilot's
blood dripping from the titan's head
recent peace mikamara obviously big giga
loves this character and he like
literally wears the disguise in public
so i wonder if perhaps he found kakichi
to be an extremely human character who
to everyone else seemed bad but you know
us readers we realized there was an
entire level to his thoughts that no one
else had even considered from the
beginning anyways after leaving ghetto
suggests to mojito that perhaps he was
cutting it a little too close but mojito
believes that it was all according to
plan
ten days later we arrive at the moment
you have all been waiting for to what is
the absolute criminally crop of hands
like oh my god i can't even right now
nothing and jjk even compares so far to
the absolute brutality that happens next
so yes finally on october the 31st 2018
the record of shibuya incident begins at
7 pm when a curtain is cast with a 400
meter radius in the middle of shibuya
city the rules of this person are that
non-sorceress can enter the curtain but
they cannot exit trapping themselves
inside juju sorcerers and managers can
move through it as they please but the
reception is blocked so all
communication has to be maintained
outside of the curtain over with our
favorite manager kiyotaka ijichi he
informs an army team of the situation
outside the curtain in the shibuya
station nanami expresses that the
situation is quite a pain while eno
tries to inform megami about the curtain
obviously megami already knows like what
occurred and everything is so he just
completely ignores him and nanami ends
up asking ajichi where gojo currently is
but meanwhile just outside of the
shibuya city business center nobody has
found where the normally busy
intersection is something terrible must
have happened and everyone would have
spread out to probably the edges of the
curtains they're all asking the exact
same thing bring satoru gojo akari
another manager from jiu jitsu tech
relays this information to the zenin
team the old dog naobiso understands
that the non-sorceress were told to say
it sorcerers are free to move in and out
of the curtain so that makes it
impossible for them to break the barrier
with brute force the ideal strategy is
to look for and neutralize the curse
user who cast the curtain however each
team is on standby for now because the
higher-ups decided that gojo should work
alone to suppress the shibuya incident
as quickly as possible
inside the curtain the civilians dressed
in their halloween costumes or discussed
the situation at 8 31 pm saturday gojo
arrives inside of the curtain and makes
his way inside of the hikari shin kyu's
shibuya shopping mall he analyzes the
situation and heads straight down to
basement floor 5 the lowest level
basement where the subway trains operate
at aoyama cemetery the meimei team
awaits further instructions yuji is
eager to help and may may surmises
they'll be called in as back up shortly
wee-wee meimei's freaking weird younger
brother feels that she shouldn't be used
in such a way okay
one sec i just need to cut myself off
here like i get it bro your sister is
absolutely banging and stuff but it
doesn't mean you need to go like all
incesty bit well anyway they then get a
message that another curtain has
appeared along with gojo's arrival
because of this meimei's team turns and
runs towards meiji station back with my
dad satoru he descends into the tokyo
metro onto a specific platform of failed
to pronounce probably way too many damn
times to even bother trying to say again
where he's confronted by chogo hanami
and cho so satoru tells joko to not have
an excuse for losing this time and joker
replies that the strongest sorcerer
should have his first ever excuse ready
sick burn joker choker hitting him with
a freaking sick burn hanami's roots
block all possible exits but gojo claims
he wasn't going anywhere anyway everyone
standing on the outside lanes of the
platform is suddenly forced onto the
tracks surrounding the fortuitously used
with non-sorcerers saturno nonchalantly
tells those around him to stand out of
his way if they don't want to die he
realizes that blocking the exits created
a blind spot so he can't break through
just in case there are people on the
other side heading for gojo jogo burns
through several civilians and chosen
attacks with slicing exorcism both
hinami and jogo attack saturday but are
instantly stopped by his infinity they
strengthen their cursed energy and
activate domain amplification forcing
saturday to dodge he surmises that they
learn this technique from a curse user
as normal barriers are meant to trap
their targets in a box but domain
amplification metaphorically surrounds
the target with water like curse energy
with this method the curses can
neutralize the infinity for those who
are like obviously still confused i just
think of kalua and his like quick as
[__] reflexes when he trains the uh like
during that dark game to get his like
reflexes up with the electricity and
shooting like
grab it as soon as things hit the skin
that's just kind of like what i think
domain amplification's like in my head
but i'm probably utterly wrong i don't
know someone let me know down below
prior to the shibuya incident ghetto
advises his allies that gojo is best
when he's working alone any juju
sorcerers and non-sorceress will only
restrict his movements and render him
incapable of using his curse techniques
in this situation satoru would be forced
on the defensive and even his domain
expansion would harm people so he
explains that the plan is to mess around
and force gojo to think of
counter-measures for a period of time
until the prison realm is ready back in
the battle djogo snatches somebody's
head off and reminds saturday the rules
were for him to not run away
saturday admits he was surprised and
joker was pleased to hear a possible
excuse however gojo rejects this and
removes his blindfold revealing his six
eyes then adding that he's only
surprised because these foolish curses
believed they could use their brain to
defeat him looking at hanami he points
him out and says that this is their
third meeting and their weed is getting
cut first without fear saturday walks
right up to jogo while ignoring hanami
beside him they both move to attack but
saturday counts as jogo's hand with his
own body he avoids an army strike and
snaps jogo's arm clean off then uses it
to block konami's follow-up attack and
continues to chase after jogo hanami
realises sasudu only made the threat
earlier to confuse them and not only
that he also deactivated his limitless
technique he questions if gojo plans to
abandon focusing on his technique and
fight in close quarters instead because
of this hanami decides it's best to
deactivate his amplification and
activate his innate technique however
this turns out to be a fatal mistake as
jojo turns back to yell at hinami sato
instantly grabs the tree branches
growing out of the hanami's eye sockets
then forcibly pulls them out completely
from his skull saying this jogo runs
away in fear shocked that satoru was
still so strong while only using cursed
energy manipulation and physical attacks
chozo attempts to hit gojo with blood
manipulation while killing civilians
along the way but it's stopped by gojo's
infinity satsuru recognises that chozo
is a death painting and decides to
ignore him for now jogo and hanami both
attack him again with domain
amplification however this time due to
the now weakened hinami satoru can
counter by strengthening his infinity he
turns and crushes an army against a wall
with his expanded limitless jogo
attempts to divert his attention by
threatening civilians but satoru doesn't
hesitate to crush an army completely
annihilating the curse with his infinity
turning them into nothing but a mist of
blood with an army exercised gojo turns
back to meet the despair joko's gaze and
claims he's next
skipping away from the absolute
domination god is laying down in shibuya
right now we find ourselves with yuji
maymay and wee-wee as they arrive at
meijiji jingju may station and that is
the last time i'm ever saying the full
name for that station where they are
informed that there are two barriers now
surrounding the station after being
informed about the situation meimei uses
her ability on some crows to investigate
the immediate area when she finishes
scouting she informs yuji of what she
saw in the station yuji asks if mojito
was down there but meimei replies that
she didn't see him however he must be in
there since there are mutated humans
literally all over the place maymay then
says that they will split up until they
each finish their respective tasks at
903 pm as usual enters another entrance
he comes across a random bug cursed
spirit who can talk and is obviously
somewhat strong yet
this thing is just like so damn relevant
it doesn't even get a name well it does
it's like grasshopper or kogai but still
you try finding a name that isn't just
grasshopper or some japanese texts that
translate to grasshopper it's that's all
that's out there i can't find anything
else yuji asks the spirit if mojito was
here twitch debug says that he is down
below and that he is currently
protecting the barrier as yuji wonders
if the bug creature had put up his
screen he notices an object and realizes
the cursed spirit was only guarding the
item that projects the screen the
grasshopper curse tells yuji that
transfigured humans don't taste as good
as normal ones and that he knows this
because he's smart annoyed yuji kicks
the curse into the wall he quickly
follows up with a punch to the grass of
his torso and states that the curse
needs to stop looking down on humans the
grasshopper says that yuji isn't smart
and those who aren't smart die i
actually hate this grasshopper man he
asks what kind of curse yuji thinks he
is and yuji is able to pick up on the
obvious answer this makes the
grasshopper curse realise that yuji is
actually smart like actual pug brain man
dude deserves to be in a bug's life not
jjk
you're making a lot of sense i mean why
take the risk you should tell hopper
good idea
yeah that's good
it's good
lower lower
hey a hop go away that's fine then i
won't tell you my idea good the
grasshopper curse lunges at yuji with
his jumping power and tries to chomp
down on him yuji avoids the attack while
assessing its strengths recognizing its
ability to communicate makes it a more
powerful curse it gets behind yuji and
tries to punch him but yuji can talk to
his body and continues to avoid getting
hurt
the dumbass grasshopper asks if yuji is
smart and his student reveals to it that
smart people don't generally ever brag
about being smart this genuinely shocks
the grass of a curse who covers his
mouth from surprise like
dude i i can't even right now for like
like being serious i can't be serious
with this dude they then engage in close
quarters and trade blows degrasso
believes it has the advantage in a
numbers battle because it has two more
arms however yuji easily overpowers and
batters his opponent with far superior
skill the grasshopper curse attempts to
shoot black mucus at yuji but he ducks
under and prepares to deliver an
uppercut however grasshoppers actually
have an expandable abdomen to lay eggs
underground and he uses this in an
attempt to strike gucci with the
extended hard tip while he's low yuji is
fast enough and knocks the appendage
aside before separating it completely
will they chop he then exercises this
stupid little grasshopper before
breaking the stake and undoing the
curtain meanwhile maymay kills the
transferred humans on the basement floor
4 and maymay decides that they should
stay and wait to regroup with yuji
before heading down to the fifth level
below them mahido prepares to board the
train from harajuku to shibuya station
he notices that the grasshopper curse
was defeated and admits that it must
have taken a skilled sorcerer to do so
mojito expresses his disappointment
having desired to fight as well but
knows what he must do and sticks to the
plan back in the beat down with our boy
gojo joko frantically huffs the air as
he runs stumbling through the crowded
platform saturday follows close behind
him with an extremely dark and menacing
presence our brother choso lets joko
take all the heat while quietly trying
to hide in the chaos among the civilians
joko tries to push people in saturday's
way and strike from behind but the
infinity is able to stop the person in
midair as well as jogo's punch chouso
nonchalantly shoots three blood arrows
from a good distance down the platform
the infinity stops them and saturn knows
chosen's location but chooses to ignore
him again honestly thank gojo for real
he didn't just mur choso first thing
like he knew he knew something was going
on behind the scenes
anyway still worrying joko believes that
20 minutes should have passed already
down the line though ghetto waits with
the gone and states that they need to
get gojo on edge more before they make a
move meanwhile at meiji stations fourth
floor the maymay team regroups and heads
down one more floor on the way down
mameka means yuji and states his
strengths yuji replies by revealing that
it wasn't mojito on the second floor and
it wouldn't have been that easy if it
was
carrying his sister's battle axe where
he sternly tells yuji to graciously
accept his sister's compliment honestly
this cuck of a kid needs to just leave
he's literally just a vehicle bro after
reaching the third floor they find a
civilian but his head immediately trans
figures and he dies before he died
though he mentioned everyone was on the
train this makes yugi realize that it's
headed straight for where gojo is back
at hikari shinku's station satoru was
surprised to see that the train is
arriving some of the civilians attempt
to get on and flee but it's already
stuffed to the brim with transfigured
humans that start attacking as soon as
they are left loose saturn watches in
horror while mojito hops out of the
train to greet jo go civilians run away
in fear as transfigured humans rush from
the train indiscriminately attacking
everyone inside saturday watches in
horror and doesn't believe whittling
down the numbers of humans as to his
opponent's advantage mohito tries
attacking flying through the air swiping
at gocho but he easily blocks it he then
figures out quickly that mojito is the
one that attacked yuji and an army and
tries to attack him but mojito jumps
back out of the way the creepy boy then
comments about how he finds humans so
disgusting since there are so many of
them and as he says this people begin
pouring down into their floor from above
as gojo figures they're the cursed
spirits have allies who are above
sending more people to their location
mojito uses idol transfiguration
multiplicity body repel and choso in
combination uses his blood manipulation
convergent supernova technique to attack
a crowded gojo however gojo easily
blocks them killing a bunch of civilians
in the process from behind joko appears
launching at gojo the sorcerer manages
to grab his arm but yogurt instantly
saves the limb to get away mohito and
joko think about the current situation
believing gocho won't use his technique
as he doesn't want to incur any more
civilian casualties yet obviously these
negative iq eggs are absolutely shocked
when gojo goes goth mode and activates
his freaking domain expansion saturday's
all or nothing domain expansion of 0.2
seconds cast an unlimited void over the
platform the time was an educated guess
that assumed non-sorcerers could only
stay within the domain for that long
without suffering permanent damage in
that time half a year's worth of info
flooded into everyone's brains
immobilizing them at this level these
special great curses could awaken at any
moment taking that into consideration
saturday focuses on killing all of the
transfigured humans and in approximately
299 seconds one thousand transfigured
humans were annihilated after the
deactivation of the domain by the hands
of the strongest man alive
immediately after saturday notices a
small box appear next to him on the
floor with the stage set for their plan
to succeed ghetto finally activates the
prison realm in a flashback before the
battle is explained that the prison
realm is the final remains of the
buddhist monk genshin impact it is a
living barrier capable of stealing
anything even gojole
joko inquires about the conditions and
kirta reveals that the target must stay
within a four meter radius for one
minute annoyed at the absurdity of this
zogo threatens him beginner was sure
joko not to worry as his version of one
minute is slightly different
in the present ghetto orders the prison
realm to open the cursed object breaks
out of its talisman seal and expands
into a cycloptic curse with an eye in
the center the eye meets saturday's gaze
and he instantly attempts to flee
however ghetto reveals himself and
greets saturday as if he had never even
died in the first place confused
memories of his best friend rushed
through satoru's mind and he still can't
understand how ghitto could even be
alive he's sure he killed him himself
but his eyes tell him something else
when ghetto said one minute to jogo in
the past he meant one minute worth of
time that processed within saturday's
six eyes enhanced brain although it was
just a moment three years worth of
memories flooded in causing the prison
realm to instantly capture gojo
immobilizing him and shutting off all
access to his body's cursed energy
recognizing that he is lost he still
demands and know who getto is as gojo
knows in his heart that suguru is dead
and that this man is a fraud
the man then removes these stitches and
takes off the top of his head revealing
the true villain of the entire series i
think and that he is indeed capable of
switching bodies along with using that
said bodies possessed natural abilities
saturday was still confident that yuta
will step in in his place however big
brain ghetto argues yuta ikotsu cannot
become the next saturday gojo he bids
farewell to satoru and tells him he will
release him into the new world after his
plan has succeeded so you know he will
come back eventually meanwhile down the
line team meimei heads towards
saturday's position
suddenly yuji stops and as you asks
what's up he finds a small mikamaru like
communication device randomly on his ear
asking if he can hear his voice
yuji is quick to take it off and
attempts to break it but kokichi quickly
reveals that sato gojo has been sealed
back at the station the imposter
addresses gojo and mockingly bids him
good night to which gojo replies by
saying that it might be good night for
him but for him it's time to wake up and
ghetto's arm suddenly moves up grabbing
his own neck ghetto is even stunned by
this and tells mojito his theory about
their body and soul being separate must
be incorrect satoru tells them to get
this over with anger agrees closing the
gate and selling satoru gojo at last
meanwhile maymay doesn't believe kokichi
but he provides information around his
own death saying that he was killed by
mojito on october the 19th on october
the 19th and that this puppet is simply
a contingency plan there are only three
of these puppets in separate locations
and one was given to meimei's team
because they are the least likely to be
the actual moles kikichi warns them that
there is a curse user coming to attack
them saying that they are stronger than
the grasshopper and likely around
semi-grade one neime wants to ignore
them and reach gojo but kokichi advises
them to focus on taking down the four
barriers that have appeared around
shibuya all the teams on standby there
have likely been caught inside a curtain
and are unable to use cell phones this
goes for managers as well so kikichi
tells yuji to head back to meiji station
and then go over to shibuya above ground
from there kikichi asks meimei to defeat
the curse user and clear the path for
yuji to what she agrees kihichi
understands the jujutsu world and human
society will be absolutely ruined if
gojo disappears so he asks them to put
their lives on their line to save him
maymay notes that their enemies have
arrived and this ugly ass curse user
abena appears with his shikagami on a
chain back at the hikari building choso
and jogo finally awakened from the
estate after the unlimited void suddenly
the prison realm drops to the ground out
of ghetto's hand cracking the floor
inside satoru sits in an unknown area
surrounded by skeletons and notices that
time doesn't pass he admits he messed up
but believes everything will be fine
because he has faith in everyone else
teams kusakabe zenin and nanami all
discuss the situation outside the curtin
team nanami agrees amongst themselves
that the most concerning new development
is the appearance of another curtain
trapping gojo and preventing sorceress
from entering it's already been almost
an hour since gojo arrived in shibuya so
from their perspective it's difficult to
understand why the enemy would wait
until now nani decides to head for the
curtains caster and asks ino and
megamike to do their best to rescue
civilians all three teams of jiu jitsu
sorcerers then head into shibuya at the
same time outside the perimeter of the
curtain ajichi talks on the phone with
the other manager akari he asked her to
confirm the situation inside the curtain
and get back out as quickly as possible
ajit plans to get everyone off duty
involved but before he can do that he's
suddenly stabbed from behind by the
freaking creep haruta shigemo pulls his
sword from ajijic's guts and watches him
fall onto the ground from behind a
mysterious monk orders him to continue
targeting the people in suits around the
curtains perimeter then hit inside after
back in shibuya station big brain ghetto
explains that the prison run requires
time to process gojo before it can be
moved mahito suddenly notices one of
mykomoro's communication devices on the
roof nearby and destroys it kokuchi
immediately relays the information about
the enemy being unable to move gojo to
ug he says that it's best to move in on
the shibuya station from the surrounding
subways and once all the curtains
preventing the sorceress from reaching
gojo are down they can then take the
station simultaneously yuji runs into
the curtain trapping civilians and using
his blinding speed and cursed energy he
clears out the group of transfigured
humans to help rescue the civilians yuji
keeps up the momentum and then climbs a
large building with ease before yelling
out in an army yuji's scream echoes
throughout shibuya reaching an army team
duty continues yelling revealing that
gojo sensei was sealed team kusukabe
hears this as well and a new shocks
nanami to the point he immediately
changes plans megami is also surprised
to hear that his mentor has been sealed
and an army says that if it is true then
all humans in japan are surely doomed
ghetto gets mahito jogo dagon and choso
into a group and informs them of his
next move he'll remain here to protect
the prison realm and asks the cursed
users on how they plan on dealing with
all of these sorcerers hitting their way
chosu simply wants to avenge his
brothers by killing yuji and obara to
which jogo says that yuji is off limit
for being zukun's vessel but cho so
simply doesn't care mojito tells joko to
calm down and playfully reveals that he
wants to kill yuji too after seeing gojo
in person mahiro is confident that their
side already holds a solid advantage
over the sorcerers and that they can win
without sakuna's help he expresses his
unusually messed up smirk and instead
suggests that they all try to kill yuji
annoyed jogo asks if mojito is being
serious and he replies that he is for
real jogo knows that sakuna isn't the
ally and could cause them all to suffer
but the error of curses will still
surely come regardless he believes
curses do not fear death and can walk
their paths sincerely to achieve their
goals mahiro argues that even if a
cursed spirit is constant along that
path they still live according to their
desires he acknowledges that reviving
sukuna is a legitimate strategy but
mojito doesn't want to fight jojo over
it instead mojito turns it into a game
if he encounters yuji first he'll kill
him and if jogo finds him first he can
use the fingers to restore sakuna's
power chozo adds that if he finds yuji
he will try to kill him as well this
annoys jogo but mojito is excited to see
that choso wants to play too guido
decides to pass on the game and stay
behind with the prison realm joko
interrupts and argues that it's the
safest and smartest strategy for them
all to remain in place with ghetto and
wait for yuji and all the remaining
sorcerers to come to the m however
mojito choso and even dagon run off once
the game starts determined to not let
them find yuji first jogo runs off as
well and inadvertently decides to take
part
instantly after ghetto notices mimiko
and nanako watching him and says that
the curses are smarter than them they
state that they helped with killing
monkeys and demand sugurugero's body
back as promised they don't want the
imposter using their beloved master's
body any longer getter refuses though
and tells the girls that they should
make a binding vow whenever dealing with
a sorcerer he tells them to leave unless
they want to be killed by their master's
body which is freaking insanely brutal
man they disappear into the crowd and
claim he'll live to regret this but the
imposter responds where they claim that
it's been so long that he's forgotten
what regret even feels like it's just a
pretty badass thing to say meanwhile
yuji stands on top of a building in
shibuya and continues yelling for nanami
after nanami's team find him yuji and
mikamaru bring them completely up to
speed as far as the situation revolving
around gojo nanami agrees coordinating
an attack from the adjacent stations
makes sense for a battle plan but in
order for that to work they must lift
the curtain first the nami asks eno to
take the first years and lower the
curtain prohibiting the sorceress from
entering the station whereas he's going
to hit outside the curtain and meet up
with the gichi additionally nami wants
eno to pass along any information to the
other teams if he encounters them after
the grade one source relieves aino
debris megami and yuji so they
understand the severity of failure in
this situation if satoru gojo disappears
the gojo family falls out of power and
anyone like yuji who is being protected
will be targeted by the jujutsu
higher-ups sorcerers and the community
will fight for political power and while
they're doing that all the curses and
curse users that were held back by
gojo's presence will attack this means
if the juju high sorcerers fail here in
shibuya the age of humanity will surely
be over in japan
meanwhile on top of the shibuya tower
three curse users watch over the
commission curtains they're excited to
hear that gojo has been sealed the old
man wonders how this will affect japan
to which ogami replies that nothing will
change as cursed users will curse and
the cursed will die
yuji tries to break through the curtain
preventing the sorceress from entering
but the attack is ineffective and the
barrier doesn't even budge eno is
impressed with yuji's striking power but
this just means that the curtain is
incredibly sturdy as megami's divine dog
totality kills transfigured humans in
the background to save civilians he
suggests that they try and find a weak
point in the curtain eno argues that
there is no weak point since they can't
get inside he believes that the curtains
caster is within the curtain but yuji
explains how curtin's worked at meiji
station by staying outside the curtain
the risk of being seen increases and in
return the curtain strength does as well
hearing this megami surmises that the
curtains projectors are probably
somewhere extremely obvious
at 10 01 pm on top of shibuya tower giro
or gyro i don't know how to say his name
exactly awasaka looks down on the city
and asks if this is the most obvious
spot to strengthen the curtain ogami's
grandson agrees but notes that they will
have to kill the curses inside the
building before getting to them however
they're both taken off guard when norway
suddenly appears flying above them as
norway goes in one direction yuji goes
on the other then using a wire he wraps
up all of the curse users at once
ogami's grandson helps you get out of
harm's way but awakasa is swept clean
off of the building takuma takes his
chance to break one of the curse tools
that is putting up the screen but also
realises that one of the enemies has
taken the other two curse tools with him
preventing him from continuing yuji
further wraps up awasaka and a wire and
drags him downward at a faster velocity
yuji snaps the wire and dives inside the
building while yelling out for megami to
deactivate norway while dropping awasaka
over 40 stories towards the ground below
back at the top of the tower facing off
with origami and her grandson eno says
that it's time for him to start paving
his way to becoming a grade one jiu
jitsu sorcerer and passionately lowers
his mask over his face back below megami
flares up his cursed energy and demands
that the old man gets up awasaka stops
playing dead and smiles at his opponents
megami reminds yuji that they don't have
time to waste and he agrees on top of
shibuya tower cursed energy flows from
aeno's body as he activates his innate
technique auspicious beast summon eno
possesses a science curse technique that
allows him to become a spiritual medium
by hiding his face in doing so he can
summon and use the abilities of four
auspicious beasts first eno summons
kaichi and shoots a horn-like projectile
with homing missile capabilities at the
two however ogami's grandson puts his
body on the line to protect durr anu
thinks that he wants to rape up this
fight as quickly as possible and get
back to the first years because nanami
entrusted him with looking after them he
tells himself to understand the effects
and control the self in order to
eliminate one's ego meanwhile yuji and
migami fights alongside the divine dog
totality against awasaka the boys don't
find fighting the enemy difficult but
working together to be the hard part of
this battle they appear to be
overwhelming the old man but he remains
completely unscathed despite all of the
efforts he slices at yuji with a knife
but gets caught in the toad's tongue and
flung into the bridge structure above
him however he still isn't hurt annoyed
megami points out that they weren't
meant to be wasting time back at the top
of the tower ogami's grandson defends
the old witch from takuma's barrage of
attacks while she continues chanting
behind him as ugami finishes her
grandson swallows something and starts
to transform into the literal civilian
demon the destroyer of freaking worlds
daddy koji fushiguro though in typical
japanese manga cliffhanger style like i
can already see in this being the point
in episode ends on it skips away back to
december the 7th 1989 the day saturday
gojo was born
in the past cursed users were free and
used their techniques to kill others for
money however that all changed that day
with his presence in the world the
balance of the jujutsu community was
completely altered the curse users were
stripped of their freedom and that
feeling of dissatisfaction has stuck
with osaka and ogami ever since in the
present day osaka continues fighting
with yuji and megami he uses his lust
for revenge on gojo to fuel his anger in
battle and beats back the two first
years this surprises these students as
they don't understand how he's
nullifying all of their damage megami
figures out that it might be related to
his innate technique and decides to yell
out a boldfaced lie he says that gojo is
in shibuya yuji is confused but this
helps megami confirm that the cursed
user's technique isn't something like
damage nullification they could counter
gojo's limitless technique awasaka
claims that he's ready to finish their
battle and megami responds by unleashing
his new rabbit escape shikagami this
creates a wave of countless small
rabbits that are supposed to serve as a
distraction however abu saka has a
random reaction to them as he's hit way
harder than he should have been this
gets megami's attention and he
immediately tells yuji revealing that
he's figured out the enemy's curse
technique
confused takumaino looks across the roof
of the shibuya tower at ogami and her
grandson who is shaped shifted into
toshi for shiguro and it figures out
that the old woman is a necromancer and
he can tell with just one look that toji
is ridiculously strong the jiu jitsu
sorcerer attempts to summon his
auspicious beast ryu but toshi rips off
his mask before eno even knows what's
happening he then lands a powerful right
hook on the sorcerer's jaw followed up
by grabbing anu's collar and pummeling
his face with a flurry of rapid fire
punches down below awasaka realizes the
purpose of megami's rabbits is more of a
diversion than an actual attack he
wonders if the jews who hire students
who tried to hit him with a lethal blow
from behind with the rabbits when
suddenly the curses are deactivated and
megami's max elephant falls from the sky
with him on top of its arwasaka manages
to resist the impact and the shukigami
is deactivated just as quickly as it
appeared this annoys the old man who
demands megami to man up and fight him
directly megumi replies that that's more
of his boy's style and right on cue you
he hears a freaking car at osaka the
cursed user is able to nullify the blow
though but it's still blown away by
yuji's pure strength
me then gets awasaka's attention while
yuji prepares a full power swing awasaka
believes he can easily anticipate yuji's
punch and megami's attack at the same
time as his curse technique inverse
makes strong attacks weak and weak
attacks strong he believes the harder
his opponents fight the easier he wins
it is revealed though that our boys had
already figured out their opponent's
innate technique and megan me surmises
that the inverse technique must have a
maximum and minimum limit as the cursed
user is reinforcing his body with cursed
energy on top of it understood and
suggested that they attack with a strong
and weak attack at the same time megami
agrees stating that they just need to
keep the pressure on and prevent him
from realizing that they've figured it
out in the present exchange of blows
yuji makes contact and his punch is
instantly nullified but a simple poke
from megami's toad's tongue is enough to
do serious damage awasaka pulls blood
from his mouth and before he even has a
chance to recover the guys resumed their
beat down injured for the first time in
this battle awasaka refuses to lose and
forces the boys back demanding the kids
don't get cocky suddenly yuji gets
behind the old man and throws another
powerful punch awasaka turns around to
counter it but yuji stops just before he
adjusts his strike throwing and now
weaker punch which awasaka's inverse
makes extremely powerful knocking him
completely out impressed by this megami
tells yuji that he can pull off some
pretty dope ass moves with awasaki
defeated yuji and megami break the two
commissioned curtains he was holding
deactivating the curd and preventing
sorceress from entering shibuya station
as megami thinks about interrogating the
old man for some answers eno is suddenly
thrown from the top of shibuya tower
megami notices in time to summon nue to
rescue him from falling to his death
yuji catches eno and is horrified by the
shape he's in above them in toji
foshigoro's form ogami's grandson
comments that the curtain is down and
asks what they should do now ogami asks
him to go down and keep killing
sorcerers however toji's personality
tears its way through taking over the
body of the grandson and telling the old
hag to not give him orders worried ogami
jumps back not understanding how this
happened is she only meant to summon the
body's information and not be soul koji
doesn't even know what's happening
either but he figures his heavenly
restricted body overtook the host's soul
ogami doesn't believe this to be
possible yet to her dismay toshi decides
to follow her orders starting off by
killing the old hag first yuji wants to
go back up the tower and avenge eno but
megami reveals that he's not dead and
asks yuji to focus on rescuing gojo
while yuji heads to the station megami
agrees to take care of eno the lesser
doesn't like the idea of being alone in
shibuya but yuji is confident and having
mikamaru with him which is you know like
pretty funny when you think about it
because the dude's just the damn
earpiece and like bro ain't helping with
any of the hands meanwhile the nami is
left horrified as he finds the jichi
unconscious and bleeding out at shibuya
station at the same time between the
stations meimei easily overwhelms the
curse user abena in close combat with
her battle axe olkidio sits on top of
abena's defeated curse spirit as meimei
explains how her innate technique works
maymay grew up believing her black bird
manipulation was a weak technique so she
focused on being effective without it
ibina begs for her forgiveness and asks
to leave but wheyu tells him to be quiet
while his sister is speaking mama
explains that reinforcing one's body
with cursed energy can only take a
sorcerer so far realizing this meimei
was initially devastated but the
realization allowed her to go back and
master her innate technique making
meimei into the blossoming grade one
sorcerer she is today wee-wee weirdly
claps and makes abeena clap for his
sister as well mammy asks her brother
why person's life value is proportional
to to what she says that life's value is
in proportion to how useful they are to
may may i love maymay bro but like i
couldn't imagine how cringed this would
be like in real life since the little
kid say that [__] she then asks sabine
his server's potential and he's unable
to answer mamimy believes the fact that
he can't answer as a curse user and a
murderer is the reason that he lost she
crushes his head with her axe and
reveals service potential as life itself
for her wee tells her sister that the
curtain has been taken down and mae mae
gets excited at the prospect of gojo
owing her big time girl watches her
movements from the shibuya station and
is impressed she wants her quickly
meanwhile on shoto bunkamaru benkamura
street i'm not saying that one again the
creep user shigimo encounters a rata and
nobara in the middle of the road nobara
tells anita to stay behind her and steps
up to face the curse user alone after
slaying so many male managers shigemo is
excited to finally find some girls to
play with which if i remember correctly
is like the exact same thing he said at
the end of the goodwill arc the dude is
just like a degenerate person
personified returning from taking ijichi
to safety nanami tells himself that he
never has or never will be frustrated by
his own uselessness he feels that he's
just living in the face of all of the
evils in the world he thinks about his
fallen homies and mutters aloud how dare
they
meanwhile this henan team fights against
the transfigured humans inside of
shibuya akarinita notifies them that it
sounds like ejichi was attacked while
they were on the phone maki tells
nabarro and akari to go check on ajichi
while she stays with the old man while
on the way nobara and akari are
confronted by the curse user shigemo
navarro believes that shigemo is the one
who attacked ijichi and she asks anita
to pretend to hide in the subway
entrance while escaping through to
another shigemo interrupts the
whisperings by throwing her sword at
nabara but she deflects it with her
hammer and charges at him confident that
he's a mid-range fighter suddenly
shigemo figures out that akari's not
actually hiding as akari runs through
the station she passes by shigemo's hand
sword hanging off a wall this leads
shigemo right to her location where he
runs up to her and delivers a soccer
styled kick straight to the manager's
chest upsetting nobara and injuring
akari navara tries to stop him but the
sword suddenly falls into shigemo's hand
allowing him to slash nabarro's leg
leaving a shallow card the cut distracts
nobara's attention allowing shigemo to
attack her upper body with a sword
landing a fierce right hook to her jaw
completely dazing our girl nabarro loses
her balance and falls onto her knees she
can't believe how perfectly her opponent
keeps landing shots she even asks
snowbarra if she's concussed nearly over
to talk to her in a taunting manner he
claims that she's gotten a lot stronger
since they last met but it doesn't
matter in the face of his uncanny curse
technique namara tries to buy time by
asking shigemo about his motivations
however he doesn't have any convictions
and kills simply because it's fun for
him he cuts akari while she's on the
ground angering nobara she tells him to
stop and he replies mockingly by asking
her to make him stop nibara stumbles
back to her feet determined to save
akari and just as shigemo prepares to
finish her off they both detect an
extremely powerful presence
nanami the big man himself walks into
the substation and immediately glares at
the curse user with a very less than
happy expression on his face shigemo
notices nanami's attire and wonders if
he's supposed to kill non-black suits
too by the way like you are about to
witness the strength of a pure 9-5
working man while shigemo wonders if he
can kill non-black suits nabarro
recognizes nanami as the leader of
megami's team the cursed user tells the
newcomer to read the room as nanami
wraps his necktie around his fist and
walks towards him shigemu tries to show
that he has he hostage but akari had
called up the escalator while he was
distracted while he expresses that he's
sad that she got away nanami appears
directly behind him he asks jigimo how
many curse users there are and where
they are located shigemo turns around to
quickly slash an army and his shoulder
claiming he doesn't know he tries to
follow up with a kick but it feels like
he's hitting a stone wall nanami doesn't
budge an inch and he's not cut at all
either surprising the assailant and now
he repeats his question asking where and
how many enemies there are shigemo is
about to claim that he doesn't know
again but nanami uses his ratio
technique to create a weak point in the
opponent's body and back hands to mofo
seen in him flying across the entire
room like dude actually got dead handled
so good shigemo bleeds profusely from
his face as his legs shake and he's
barely able to stand he believes he
should have died and credits his curse
technique for saving his life he wants
to run but nanami grabs his hair and
repeats his question once again before
shigemo can even answer an army delivers
a ferocious body shot that slams shigemo
into the wall behind him shattering it
upon impact with his life in very
imminent danger the curse user calls his
curse to rescue him it flies through the
air in an attempt to slash an army from
behind but nobara nails it to the wall
shigemo tells her to stay out of it but
nanami interrupts and grabs him by the
throat instead of replacing the question
again nanami reveals he found several
dead managers on his way here he lifts
his fist and charges it with cursed
energy asking if shigemo is responsible
terrified the helpless piece of trash
apologizes but it's too late as daddy
hits him with his curse technique
smashing the boy's face leaving him in
an unconscious bloody heap nobara is
amazed by nanami's strength nothing that
he is exactly the model of what it means
to be a true grade one jujutsu sorcerer
he walks away from the defeated child
and tells novara that they need to find
akari meanwhile yuji dashes through the
humans getting massacred all throughout
the streets he wants to help but there
isn't enough time to save everyone in
this massive crowd either however lucy
hears a familiar voice that might be
able to save the day toge anumaki my
favorite mew arrives with a megaphone in
hand and immediately speaks to the
entire crowd commanding everyone to not
move surely after helping toge rescue
the civilians yuji enters shibuya
station at around 10 10 pm unbeknownst
to yuji cho so waits inside the station
to confront his brother's killer back
with nanami he kneels over as he speaks
with nobara and ikari he reveals that
the jichi will be okay but tells the
girls to not forget that ajichi
originally trained to be a sorcerer
instead of a manager so how ghosts built
kind of different you know nobara and
akari also learn about gojo's situation
something they didn't hear about as they
were indoors during yuji's yelling
nanami asks them to wait for rescue
while he joins the xeno team and heads
for shibuya station nobara wants to go
but nanami insists that the coming
battle requires grade 1 and above
sorcerers anyone else would simply be in
their way meanwhile underground maymay
comes face to face with ghetto she's
surprised to see him but quickly
dismisses the idea that he could be
alive yetu tries to act friendly but
meimei hasn't forgotten about abina geta
replies that he feels sorry that he has
to kill a former friend and summons the
special grey disease curse the smallpox
deity to do it for him instead maymay is
surprised to see him use cursed
manipulation but still doesn't doubt her
conclusion about him for a moment ghetto
reveals that he doesn't have many curses
left after the attack on jiu jitsu tech
in the previous year but the ones he
does still possess are ones of pristine
quality he leaves the area telling may
that if she can exercise this smallpox
deity then he'll be her next opponent
the disease curse immediately activates
its domain expansion trapping meimei
inside a coffin the cursed chant's grave
causing a large gravestone to fall from
the sky onto the coffin the curse then
begins to count but maybe breaks out
before it ends wee-wee initially watches
in horror but is excited to see her
sister survive maymay is impressed
stating that it's been longer than she
can remember since her life had been in
danger for even a moment at the entrance
to shibuya yuji runs inside and
immediately finds choso who recognizes
him as his brother's killers he
activates his blood manipulation
convergence then uses the secret
technique of blood manipulation called
piercing blood the ability shoots a
condensed cursed energy reinforced arrow
extremely fast at yuji yuji is able to
block it but the attack is so fast and
nearly passes completely through his
left arm yuji tries to close the
distance right after the attack is done
and hits him with his divergent first
chozo blocks the hit but is left
confused by the double impact as the
fight comes to a pause chozo asks yuji
if his younger brothers left him with
any final words
chozo clarifies that he means the two
people yuji killed and their student
laments about what happened with a sad
expression on his face
he says that they didn't really have any
last words but they cried before they
died chosen was initially shocked but is
then quickly overcome with rage causing
the bloodline going horizontally across
his nose to bubble and distort in shape
chozu asks iso and kichizu to watch over
him as blood behind him forms an
intimidating face shaped by his malice
he tells his younger brother to take a
good look at their older brother as he
prepares to kill eugene meanwhile inside
this smallpox deity's domain expansion
maymay is momentarily trapped
underground beneath one of the disease
curse's gravestones the cursed spirit
counts down from three again but meimei
breaks out of the trap in time having
experienced this a few times now in the
fight maymay understands the process of
the technique first the target of the
domain is trapped inside a coffin and
then buried underground when they're hit
by the weight of their large gravestone
lastly the curse counts down from three
and the target is infected with the
smallpox disease the curse hits mae's
coffin with another gravestone but this
time she immediately cuts her way out
she believes this part of the process is
the most annoying and fears she won't be
able to fight ghetto freely if she's hit
again may also deduces that the domain
can only target one person at a time and
devises a counter-attack centered around
that the curse instinctively targets the
person with a stronger cursed energy and
only a single crow was caught inside the
domain so momma needs the disease curse
to focus on her brother before she can
utilize the birds she asks her little
brother if he's willing to die for her
and in his typical simp fashion he
agrees to do anything for her mammy
flees off to the side while yuyu flares
up his curse energy the disease curse
notices the swelling energy and traps
wee-wee inside of a coffin a single hit
by the gravestone would be enough to
kill him but as the cursed chant maemae
suddenly slices off its hand with her
axe the grade one sorcerer tells the
disease curse that her brother's role is
more of that than just a pack mule you
know i highly doubt but he then proves
this by activating his new shadow style
simple domain to protect himself when
mae mae asked if he was willing to die
he realized that this meant he was
actually allowed to fight mames says
that his role is to counter domains as
she doesn't like to be indebted to
anyone the special grey curse disease
heals its hand quickly and reaches out
to attack meimei when suddenly the
single bird flies through the back of
the cursed spirit piercing and
exercising it in a single blow while the
cursed bird is dying mammy asks the
quickest way to raise one's strength as
a sorcerer and her brother replies that
it will be a binding vow with one's life
as they trade off for more power
meimei's extension technique bird strike
exceeds the limits of the crow's cursed
energy by forcing it to commit suicide
with a kamikaze-like attack no one other
than satoru gojo has ever survived the
devastating attack with them defeated
maymay declares it's time for the main
act she calls a flock of crows to her
side that fill the underground subway
and asks if they're ready to die for her
from these shadows big brain ghetto
comes to confront her admitting that
she's not bad for a jujutsu sorcerer of
this era back in the heat of battle
against yuji chozo uses blood
manipulation to control the blood
outside of his body and shoot his
piercing blood attack at yuji yuji
quickly realizes it's too fast and his
chances of avoiding it are only about 50
percent muji instead decides to dictate
the timing of his opponent's next attack
by jumping off the ground this
successfully baits choso who willingly
fires passing blood again at yuji's head
just before he hits the ground however
yuji drops his upper body's weight all
the way down close to the ground at the
very moment his feet touch it quickly
avoiding the beam he then immediately
rushes towards choso and attempts to
close the distance between them chozo
commends yuji and bends the beam down to
try and hit him yuji though is from the
land of weaving leaving and is able to
dodge it then engages choso at close
range he wants to turn the exchange into
a fist fight but there's still a few
floating balls of condensed blood around
them chozo activates supernova
detonating all of the condensed blood in
every direction like a buck shot
severely injuring yuji's back big
brochuso follows up by using blood edge
to stab yuji's foot with a dagger made
of blood however yuji surprisingly
fights back with his stabbed foot and
kicks him away then using his athletic
ability to flip around chozo's guard he
lands a heavy axe kirk yuji realizes
that there aren't any more orbs of blood
and focuses on stopping him from making
any more he's caught off guard though
when cho so assumes the stance for
shooting passing blood giugi stops
running towards his opponent falling for
chozo's feigned josue then takes the
offense of casting flowing red scale on
himself and delivering several
successive blows to yuji after smashing
him up against the wall chozo uses
convergence and piercing blood to try
and finish him off however our goat
somehow has the skin of a freaking rhino
and survives chozo though admits the
blood wasn't condensed enough to kill
him still heavily injured yuji starts to
realize he can't win when randomly once
again mkhimaru starts speaking asking
what's going on he replies with his own
question asking where mikamaru has been
this whole time but he claims that he's
conserving energy because there's
something he still needs to do
chozo watches confused while mikamaru
recognizes the death painting and tells
yuji that choso is using blood
manipulation which is like pretty
obvious he says the inherited technique
is prized within the kmo family for its
overall balance in combat yuji doesn't
find this info helpful as he just
narrowly dodges another shot of piercing
blood mikumaro advises him to retreat to
the bathroom revealing that he has an
idea yuji darts into a small hallway
surprising cho so the death painting
believes that yuji will head to the end
and skew it up by piercing blood however
chozu runs into the bathroom where he
finds mkhimaru's communication puppet on
the opposite wall chozo uses piercing
blood to destroy the puppet but water
certainly bursts out of every opening
yuji who was hiding in their store
behind choso attacks him choco slides
back after blocking and believes that
that was yuji's last chance before death
he prepares to use the condensed blood
floating around him to finish the fights
but the water splashing around the room
abruptly dispels convergence chozo
doesn't quite understand what's happened
and honestly it kind of took me a little
while to probably get it as well but he
decides to use flowing red scale stack
either way focusing on controlling all
of the blood within his own body to
fight instead hugh doesn't get the logic
behind it either but he does understand
that they are fighting where he's
comfortable now in close quarters they
engage in a quick exchange of blows with
yuji gaining the upper hand however just
as yuji gets the advantage chozo used
his enhanced strength to flick a small
blood meteorite straight into yuji's
liver yuji is taken off guard because he
thought cho so was out of projectiles
thanks to mkhimaru's water track but
immediately he recognizes he's been hit
in an internal organ and considers the
thought of losing and even dying however
he stomps on the damn ground and regains
his footing this is like honestly our
boy's time freaking shine right here
yuji converts his fear into curse energy
and clears his mind of all distractions
getting ready to truly die if that's
what it takes to bring down cho so at
the same time chozo laments about how
yuji has only landed three significant
strikes yet he is moderately injured
from them he knows using another
surprise attack with blood meteorite
won't work so he improvises and hardens
his entire fist and much of his forearm
using the blood inside of his body by
doing this chosen was actually at risk
of spontaneously developing a thrombosis
but he determines that yuji is more of a
severe threat by the way thrombosis
occurs when blood clots block veins and
arteries which can like result in death
because it can't flow properly around
the body i'm pretty sure yuji and choso
exchange blows once again but yuji is
able to predict his opponent's movements
at close range he avoids a punch and a
sweeping kick before hiding in a
bathroom door and locking it this
confuses cho so but yuji suddenly bursts
through the door and drop kicks him in
the face chozo narrowly blocks with his
heart in hand but yuji locks his leg
around his opponent's head and throws
him when they flying says a takedown
while choso is staggered yuji closes the
existence and flashes his right hand as
a decoy to land a hard left blow to the
body however something just doesn't feel
right to yuji and chozo abruptly cracks
his collarbone with a violent hammer
fist to the shoulder this creates a
gaping dent where yuji's shoulder should
be leaving him vulnerable to chozo's
next attack the death painting finishes
the fight with a crushing blow to yuji's
stomach that sends him across the room
crashing into a wall chozo lifts his
robe and reveals that he had hardened
part of his body yuji attacked saying
this yuji falls unconscious still barely
breathing chosen wants to finish him off
and before doing so tells the jutsu
sorcerer to ask his brothers for
forgiveness on the other side however
something freaking mental suddenly stops
cho so like i'm gonna leave you all
freaking confused until probably the
next jujitsu kaizen explain video where
i go over the next heart this like
moment is freaking huge at that moment a
memory was born inside of chozo's brain
a memory of a past event that never
happened sukuna watches this from his
innate domain disappointed with yuji's
performance he calls his student
worthless and can't believe he lost to
such an inferior opponent suddenly
chosu's head begins to throb and he
stumbles away from yuji abruptly
stricken with a headache he recalls
eating peacefully at a picnic table with
all of his brothers somehow including
our boy yuji they were both eating
together with iso and kachizu as well as
all of the other six brothers who were
still sealed yuji even passed him some
food and called cho so his big broho so
yeah obviously i joked about big bro
choso but maybe i wasn't at the end of
the day maybe big bro toto and choso is
a thing who knows when the memory ends
joseph bends over forward as sweet drips
profusely off of his face he doesn't
understand what's going on and asks
himself why yuji was a part of that
recollection as chozo stumbles away
confused mimiko and hanukkah appear to
feed one of zacuna's fingers to the
unconscious yuji yo it's time it's time
at 10 20 pm nanami and these enemies
head towards basement floor 5. nanami
informs them about gojo ceiling and
ghetto's involvement naobi mentions he
wouldn't mind the decline of the gojo
family prompting maki to tell him to
leave if he's not going to help the head
of the xenon family believes mahi is the
one who should go home nanami actually
even agrees with naobito having left
nabarro behind due to the danger of this
mission maki though believes she's more
useful than her drunken grandfather
irritated by hearing this nanami asks
naobito if he's been drinking and the
sorcerer claims he's done nothing of the
sort as they reach the lower floors of
the station nanami thinks maybe he
should have gone alone maki notices
something while he running through and
an army says it as well an octopus-type
curse hiding behind one of the pillars
in the open area nanami draws his sword
and prepares to exercise him when
suddenly naobito appears behind the
curse he traps the premature digon in a
frame using his cursed technique and
while immobilized he lands a heavy
strike that sends the kurds flying
across the room the impact severely
injures the cursed womb causing him to
vomit up skeletal remains of the
non-sorcery humans he ate earlier
writhing in pain dagon calls out to his
allies including hanami however after
realising hanami is dead it enrages him
and forces an evolution degon leaves his
cursed womb behind and evolves into a
much larger and fishier form as he
generates a sphere of water on the top
of his finger naobito prepares for the
incoming attack endagon unleashes a
furious current that floods the entire
area maki stabs her spear into one of
the pillars and stands on top of it to
avoid the water she's shocked by the
pure volume of the water the cursed
spirit is outputting however much of the
water that comes near beethoven's way is
trapped within the frames made by his
cursed technique neobizu asks the cursed
spirit if he knows how many frames there
are in an animated sequence while de gon
is distracted by the old man nanami gets
above him and strikes using his ratio
technique digon appears to block it but
he's abruptly seen crashing into the
ground nanami attempts to follow up with
an attack of her own but dagon grabs the
blade of her curse tool before her
counter-attacks naobito traps him inside
a frame though and an army dives down to
strike the cursed spirit yet degon is
able to protect himself by generating a
whirling shield of water that circles
around him maki laments being saved by
now beto humiliated by the fact she
would have died if he hadn't stopped a
gun earlier the old man playfully slaps
dagon's shield of water and commends him
for being able to pull off multiple
simultaneous curse techniques he
recognizes the gon has massive amount of
cursed energy and likely more techniques
up his sleeve in order to counter
neobizo leads the way and claims they'll
all crush him with speed before he can
activate any more moves naobiso nanami
and maki all start attacking dagon's
watershield as fast as they can in rapid
succession each of them gradually begins
to pierce into it until naobizu's first
breaks through completely before he's
hit dagon causes the water to explode as
a distraction and levitates above making
an army however now naobito suddenly
appears behind a gone saying he foresaw
the curse attempting to flee up high he
kicks the gun onto the ground and
follows up with a barrage of brutal
blows that overwhelms the curse dagon
admits that the old man is the main
problem in this jiu-jitsu battle and
that he's even faster than joe go he
then attempts to form his fingers
together to create a hand sign but now
beto unleashes a flurry of punches that
pounded gone into the ground despite now
beto's best efforts though an uncanny
seal forms under gone stomach area
allowing him to cast his domain
expansion horizon of the captivating
skanda inside this coastal type domain
nanami and maki are both suddenly bitten
by piranha shikogami the domain's
guaranteed hit creates first shikigami
that don't even exist until they hit the
target which is honestly like just
cracked now be so though is easily able
to counter the domains can't miss attack
with a secret art falling blossom
emotion dagon figures that the head of
the xenon family had some kind of trick
up his sleeve considering his skill
level because of this he decides to
focus seventy percent of his power on
naobiso and the other thirty percent on
an army
man obviously just completely thrilled
about maki he unleashes his death swarm
technique calling upon a swarm of
shikagami to attack his foes knowing
that shukigami will instantly eat them
alive he warns maki to attack without
hesitation his warning is interrupted
though when the shukugami abruptly
appear to devour him first naobi manages
to resist the wave of shikagami using
fallen blossom emotion but still
recognizes the situation does not favor
him he notices that the force of the
shukigami isn't slowing down at all and
wonders about the technique connected to
the domain his thoughts are abruptly
stopped though when dagon hides in the
stream of shukigami and punches naobi so
high into the air as he continues to get
attacked now in the air dagon reveals
death swarm as an endless stream of
shikagami that will never stop dagon
turns to maki and says that she's the
weakest here he quickly gets behind her
and kicks her hard into the forest area
on the beach despite the heavy hit maki
survives and tells the octopus to finish
her off in one hit if he's going to
insult her strength as the gun threatens
to give her the same fate as the other
two the new generation sasuke and his
domain expansion chimera freaking shadow
garden is suddenly activated instantly
getting dagon and maki's attention
megami appears from the geyser and calls
out to our girl he extends his shadows
out to her allowing maki to pick up this
special grey curse tool playful cloud
grateful for the help maki tells megami
that he really is a cocky brat
momentarily floating above the tornado
of shadows megami looks onward over the
coastal area and notices to gone he
immediately recognizes that the octopus
like curse is the master of the domain
de gon believes megami is foolish for
entering his domain voluntarily and
prepares to attack him maki quickly
attacks dagon with the playful cloud
striking away a chunk of the cursed
spirit's arm dagon is surprised that he
was actually injured and maki follows up
with another blow that seems to gone
skidding across the ocean water he
recovers from the attacks and recognizes
that his guaranteed hit has been
nullified because of mega me locked in
her domain tug of war dagon decides it's
best to crush mega mead before doing
anything else the cursed spirit spawns
fish from his body and sends him
swimming through the water at his
adversary nanami jumps across the toads
manifested from megami's chimera shadow
garden and slices are partly fish making
me a surprise to see him and nanami asks
him about yuji and eno megami informs
him of their status and an army focuses
on protecting megami so he can
concentrate on keeping the domain open
dagon is shocked nanami managed to
withstand death swarm for an entire
minute suddenly naobito appears behind
him and attacks with blinding speed the
gun ducks under the attack and is
equally surprised that the old man has
survived as well
maki comes up to attack behind the curse
and the gun defends by spawning two
large eel-like shrigami to repel these
sorcerers naobitsu traps the one
attacking him in a frame and crushes it
with a powerful stomp maki defends
himself as well and they both stand on
opposite sides of the gun now betsy
tells him that all his attacks did was
get one arm he adds that even if he was
old and decrypted it will still cost the
curse dearly nanami continues defending
megami but the young sorcerer is
reaching his limits megami reveals that
he's actually trying to open a hole in
the domain's barrier rather than engage
in a domain battle the octopus curse
likely can't cast domain expansions
twice in the same day so if the
jiu-jitsu sorcerers can escape they win
nanami makes sure megami doesn't plan on
staying behind and the student clarifies
that he has no intention of throwing his
life away nanami calls out to the
zenings and tells them to assemble in a
roundabout way they put their trust in
nanami's words and rush towards him
digon is confused for a moment but he
quickly figures out his adversary's plan
he panics and rushes to stop them nanami
believes it's too late as a hole appears
in the ground below megami that leads
outside of the barrier you guys let me
have clue what's about to happen if you
haven't read this before like hold on to
your damn seats as everyone assembles
okay as everyone assembles around this
hole something unexpected happens before
the sorceress can even exit the domain
toji my father himself fushiguro
suddenly enters through the hole and
they're all forced to be a witness to
the flesh of the man who was truly free
in all of his overwhelming intensity
toji makes his way into dagon's domain
through the hole that megami had made in
the barrier surprise megami looked up at
the man floating in the air maki notices
the intruder is a human jujutsu sorcerer
and dagon wonders why his adversaries
would let someone in rather than escape
then in an instant toji disappears from
sight suddenly grabbing on to playful
cloud with blinding speed he easily
snatches the curse tool from maki
throwing her aside to arm himself with a
playful cloud maki didn't even notice
any cursed energy so she's shocked that
she actually lost in an exchange of pure
strength megami then reveals that the
hole he had just opened in the barrier
has been closed and it won't be easy for
him to open another neo beto is the only
one amongst them who recognizes who toji
is upon uttering his name naobito
notices the sclera of toji's eyes filled
completely with black though ogami's
science technique had the capability to
continue after death it was never meant
to last forever the technique is
supposed to end when the host's cursed
energy runs out however the grandson's
soul did not possess any cursed energy
as well and toji's body that overwrote
it did not consume cursed energy
therefore it will never end and now toji
can only fight completely on instinct
until the vessel breaks here's a puppet
of pure carnage and destruction the con
honestly messes up really bad like right
here he notices toji has no cursed
energy and says that he's a complete
waste of time he summons the shukigami
to attack batoji obliterates it in a
single swing with insane speed he then
follows up with a barrage of three
section staff strikes that injured a
gun's head sending him flying back
surprised the gun recognizes that he
grossly underestimated toji superhuman
speed and power he tries to summon a
swarm of numerous smaller shikigami to
attack but toji continues to get faster
while running on water like the god he
is toshi effortlessly rushes through all
of the fish striking them apart with a
curse tool on his way to attack dagon
dagon then summons his hardest and most
powerful shikagami to repel toji however
it's dispatched just as easily as the
rest it's explained that playful cloud
is the only special grey curse tool
without a curse technique imbued into it
it is pure and solid power that depends
entirely on the wielder's strength in
toji's hand he annihilates dagon's
watershield in a single blow slamming
the curse's head violently into the sand
dumbfounded by the newcomer's domination
maki can only watch in amazement with
everyone else she asks naobita who the
man is but he says that toji is just a
ghost nanami tells megami to hold on to
his domain for just a little bit longer
because they're going to need a bet on
toji back with toji he rubs playful
cloud together to sharpen its shape
injured dagon barely stands back up and
comes to the realization that he's
really about to lose to a human without
any cursed energy he attempts to buy
time until megami's domain runs out by
levitating in the air but once again
naobito is way ahead of him now beto
leaps on top of dagon's head and stops
his progress seeing this toji stacks
playful clouds three sections on top of
each other to vault himself into the air
directly and dagon the curse puts up his
guard but toji stabs playful clouds
straight through his face dagon believes
he can still fight but toji brutally
threads playful cloud through dagon's
head and stabs him in the eye as well he
then breaks the chain connecting the
three section staff together and rapidly
uses both sharpened sides to obliterate
to gone actually like shanking the
shikigami to death the domain is
dispelled and maki is shocked that one
lone fighter was able to exercise such a
powerful cursed spirit single-handedly
megami is exhausted from holding his
domain for so long and takes the moment
to catch his breath nanami knows that if
megami hadn't shown up they would have
all been killed but now they have a new
problem they can't be sure if tochi is
on their side or not toji is still
fighting on instinct bearing his fangs
at the strongest person around megami
may be exhausted but he's by far the
least injured so toji drags him outside
of the station in an instant before
megami can even process what's happening
he finds himself outside on the road
megami lands safely but he looks back
across his street at his opponent with a
surprised expression he claims that this
ridiculous level of speed even past his
soconus from back when they fought
earlier in the series honestly love how
megami doesn't even realize that this
guy's actually his dad i really really
can't wait for the day in the series
where he finally finds out who toji
fushiguru is or like who toji zenan is
because that's who he knows them as i'm
pretty sure maki yells out of concern
for megami but she's immediately
interrupted by a new presence behind her
jogo arrives mourning to gone and
bidding farewell to his friend joku
tells dagon to leave the race to him and
then he looks forward to their reunion
and their wastelands with the next
second jogo then has his palm placed on
an army's waist he says that's one and
blasts him with an explosive wave of
cursed flames before maki can even yell
out djoko lights her on fire as well he
says that's two and moves to claim a
third victim however naobiso gets behind
jojo surprisingly curse with his speed
neo-beto's innate technique projection
sorcery divides a single second into 24
frames and uses his field of view as the
projection's angle of view by doing so
naobito can trace a predetermined set of
movements to perform within those 24 set
frames additionally anything touched by
naomi's palm who doesn't abide by the 24
fps rule while moving will be frozen in
an animation frame for one second so
pretty much they have to do the exact
same thing as naobi two otherwise
they'll be frozen in a frame and he'll
be able to hit them the predetermined
set of movements cannot be adjusted once
started and its trajectory cannot
excessively ignore the law of physics
now beta was born with a natural sense
of strategic timing and movements so
much so he was then the fastest jiu
jitsu sorcerer excluding gojo
that being said this was when naobito
still had both arms which is kind of
like a big uf moment right there two
small volcanic openings suddenly appear
behind neobito and he cannot avoid the
crossing heat waves in time so he is
heavily burned by jogo's technique
jogo says that that's three and prepares
to finish off now beto when zacona's
strong presence abruptly gives him the
chills and grabs his attention meanwhile
nanako and mimika remember what was
going on with that with sakura's finger
they force feed him one of zacona's
fingers and jojo then finds them soon
after so those battles were like kind of
going on simultaneously so you kind of
get an understanding of how like the
fights are working right now things are
going on at the same time as this is
going on so it's all very very confusing
annoyed he demands to know how many
fingers they feed him but the girls
quickly flee while zukun's marks still
remain on yuji's face joker decides to
make the best of the situation he too
informed joko beforehand that if yuji
ate a finger for a day for 20 days he
probably wouldn't lose control of his
body to skuna in contrast though feeding
yuji 10 fingers at once might
temporarily force him to lose control
joko takes out a small scroll of 10
fingers and tells the king of curses
that it's time for him to wake up oh yes
it's that time of the freaking battle
it's time for the man himself joko looks
over to see mimiko and nanako they're
alive but they didn't manage to escape
the station completely joko also notices
that their faces indicate they're afraid
and surmises that they likely can't use
another cursed technique to get out of
harm's way while he was distracted
though the silly volcano doesn't even
realize the hand holding yuji's face had
been cut clean off jojo and the girls
are both shocked as an ominous voice
demands him to move drago darts away to
position himself next to the sisters he
notices that in comparison to gojo
sukuni's aura is filled with an
overwhelming malice honestly i i wonder
if something bad happened in his past
that sends the cooner down like an evil
path in comparison to like gojo having
like the good mindset and changing from
what he thought earlier on you know like
in the livestock just an idea because i
think i honestly think sakura used to be
a human and he's turned into a cursed
spirit because people became to fear him
over time anyway nanako believes even
one movement will result in instant
death she tells herself to just breathe
but she's unsure if even that's safe
sukuna faces them and says they're
holding their heads a little too high
the girls instantly drop along with jogo
but his isn't low enough sukuna creates
a giant gash in the wall behind the trio
that cuts off the top of jojo's head the
cursed spirit begins to bleed profusely
across his face asakuna tells him that
one knee was still too high sukuna walks
up to the girls and anako uses this
chance to ask kona if he can free
tsuguru ghetto by killing the person
inhabiting his body nanaku claims to
know where another finger is and will
tell sakuna in exchange for helping them
sakuna tells the girls to raise their
heads and gives them a smirk suddenly
mimiko's head is severed displeased
sukuna asks if nanako thought she could
order him around for just a few fingers
desperate for revenge nanaku aims his
cellphone camera at sekouna and attempts
to activate her innate technique sukuna
activates his first though and slices
the top half of nanako's head clean off
he follows up by dismantling her entire
body into tiny cubes then literally
slices her into nothing but a gruesome
spray of blood sukuni catches nanako's
phone and surmises that the camera is
connected to her curse technique saguna
says jogo is next and asks what he needs
however joku doesn't claim to need
anything this confuses zakuna and jogo
clarifies his objective is to simply
fully revive him joku implores sakuna to
make a binding vow that will let him
take over yuji's body permanently sukuni
refuses this though and reveals he has
his own plans surprising jogo amused by
the curse for its desperation sukuna
offers a token of his appreciation for
the ten fingers he challenges jogo to
land even one hit on him if yoga can
achieve this sukuna agrees to work with
his group for now and kill every human
in shibuya except for one to which jogo
willingly accepts
meanwhile back with father and son
megami tries to visualize winning but
toji is far too much of a monster to
even fathom defeating megami activates
his rabbit escape when both fighters
notice sekuna's presence suddenly
appearing in shibuya megami uses the
torrent of rabbits as a distraction to
create distance from his adversary he
also summons toad and asks himself why
he just felt sakuna toji instinctively
charges into the swamp of rabbits and
nearly stabs megami with a sharp and
playful cloud but migami dives onto the
ground and avoids hurts running low on
cursed energy megami's sole advantage is
that shoko is stationed somewhere in
shibuya flashing over there yaga says
ajiji and eno would both have perished
if not for her but joku says that that's
only thanks to the principal's quick
thinking they set up the station before
nanami even contacted them freeing him
to help up with the mission honestly i
think uh i think yaga might actually be
the mole who was feeding stuff to the
higher ups and it wasn't even kakichi in
the first place back in the battle toji
chases after megami and nearly stabs him
from behind luckily toad's tongue pulled
megami away down an alleyway to avoid
the attack megami understands that toji
made short work of a special great and
his shivagami are no match for him he
needs to focus on sacrificing his body
rather than hijakigami and decides it's
best to limit any injuries to something
shoko can quickly handle as toshi stands
at the end of the alleyway megami
surmises that he has to predict his
opponent's timing because of his speed
and understands that any flaws in timing
will surely result in death taji
suddenly blitzes megami and nearly stabs
him again but his foot submerged inside
megami's shadows megami summons a sword
from his shadows and attempts to stab
toji with it however toji disappears in
an instant avoiding it with insane speed
megami believes that he's out of options
when toji suddenly recalls a memory of
his past it was the time when toji
agreed to meet with naobiso in order to
sell his son to the xenon family toji
believed that megami would have
potential and he could possibly make
something of himself in the future toji
never fit in but he thought that it
would be the best way to take care of
him in the long run after not speaking
any words since megami met him today
suddenly asks megami what his name is to
which the goat answers perfectly saying
fushiguro
proud that his son chose for shiguro
over zenon toshi stabs himself in the
head killing his vessel in order to save
his son from his mindless rampage his
body collapses shocking megami with the
outcome of it all and honestly this is
why toji is a goat like yeah he's strong
and his battles are probably the most
hype at this point but they do literally
killed himself for his son as soon as he
knew it was him he instantly did it like
pure chair dad as soon as he knew that
his son chose fish a girl over there and
he was like yeah man i'm out of here
megami kneels down and examines the body
of his deceased opponent he notices that
his face is changed back into ogami's
grandson and admits he was lucky that
this man decided to end it making me
thinks about what naobito said about
toji and what his opponent said about
rejecting the xenons however megami is
still injured from the fight and decides
to go see shoko as soon as possible
suddenly mega meets slash from behind by
the [__] creeper shigemo shigemo's
nose and teeth are still broken from his
fight with nanami but he's alive and
somehow moving meanwhile the kusukabe
team wanders aimlessly around shibuya
and yumaki confirmed he relocated all of
the civilians somewhere safe and that
sato gojo has been sealed panda believes
they need to hurry but kusukabi keeps
coming up with excuses to keep panda's
urgency at bay the kuzukaba team is
interrupted by the appearance of two
curse users suda and negai or suda and
niggy i don't know how to say there are
two former commanders of gesso and three
of their foot soldiers are behind
kuzukaba and panda as well kuzukaba
relishes the opportunity to fight with
other sorcerers because it can buy him
more time he asks for the sorcerer's
motivations and tells them to take as
much time as they want
manami reveals that they've inherited
sugar ghetto's will she and negai intend
on helping big prank gesso now despite
mimiko and nanako's miscavines skipping
forward to the conclusion of manami's
story she asks if kusakabe surrenders
kusukaba is disappointed this story
finished quickly but is still happy as
the situation is too good to pass up
kusukabe activates the new shadow style
evening moon sword drawing nego takes
that as his enemies answer and begins
activating a technique of his own their
fight is abruptly interrupted by an
explosion that detonates an entire
building behind negai there sukuna
pummels jogo through the ear and
dominates their fight as the latter
falls injured with blood spilling from
his mouth sukun asks if that's all he's
got and joker replies not yet joker
prepares a fire attack by concentrating
flames between his palms but zacuna uses
his innate technique to slash jogo's
arms apart while the cursed spirit is
still railing sukuna smashes his head
with a violent hammer first the impact
seems joko crashing towards the ground
but sakura catches up to him with a
quick dive in order to smash his face
directly into the top of a tall building
sukuna and joko crashed through all of
the floors of the skyscraper which
severely injures jogo as the moonlight
shines through the broken roof of the
building sukuna looks down on jogo and
says the moon's illumination makes it
easier to see how pathetic he is as joko
struggles to regenerate his dismantled
jaw among other injuries he recalls
ghetto telling him his strength is
comparable to sekuna with eight or nine
fingers absorbed despite knowing he'd be
outmatched joko contemplates to himself
that he didn't expect the difference in
their strength to be this great sukuna
suddenly appears behind jogo the king of
curses grabs his opponent's collar and
lifts him up telling him to keep going
until the fun stops flames erupt from
all of the forcefully opened holes in
the building further destroying the
structure schooner though escapes out of
the building into the street chasing him
jogo follows up using his strongest
curse technique maximum meteor for those
who don't know what a maximum technique
is pretty much that there is just like
the strongest kind of like innate or
like ability that someone can use
outside of a domain anyway anyway the
kuzukawe team and the curse users around
them notice the battle going on nearby
kuzukaba and panda attempt to flee and
are intercepted by nigai and suda's
henchmen suda tells the underlings they
don't have time to fight bakusa kabe
quickly cuts them down with new shadow
style bato sword drawing kuzukawa tells
the remaining sorcerers they need to
flee and get away from the fighting
special grades however sukuna appears
next to kusukabe in an instant and says
he won't allow any human to run sukuna
declares that all humans in his vicinity
aren't allowed to move until he says so
or else he will kill them this leaves
all of these sorcerers forced to watch
as maximum mesia falls drawing closer to
killing them all a few moments later
sukuna finally lets them all run however
this gives them little to no time as
maximum meteor crashes into shibuya
decimating the entire area with its
impacts tired from unleashing his
maximum technique jogo stands atop it
huffing for air after catching his
breath he smirks and says even an attack
that powerful must have injured kona so
kona's voice tells jojo that it would
only be the case if it hurts he then
appears sitting beside him as if he was
never in danger he asks jogo why he
won't use his domain expansion joku
admits he would lose in a domain
struggle between them and takuna
believes his lack of confidence stems
from losing to gojo in the past
entertained sukuna stands up and
suggests he begin fighting using joko's
specialty this here is freaking dope by
the way man like like sucuna starts
speaking in tongues like we don't even
know what this guy said sukuna does
something like no one even knows yet to
allow him to open and manipulate flames
joku was confused prompting sukuna to
realize a curse spirit wouldn't
understand this technique sukuna tells
joko to get ready for a fire-powered
battle sukuna and jogo stand atop the
flaming remains of maximum meteor sukuni
creates an arrow of flames from his
palms while jogo swirls his flames into
a small fireball made of compressed
energy sukuna takes aim by keeping the
arrow fully formed between his fingers
while and yeah good old gig couldn't
even write it down jogo enters a fantasy
alongside his deceased allies hanami and
dagon death is something humans fear it
is a mirror for humanity and mojito is a
manifestation of that reflection he will
continue to grow stronger joker believes
when they're all reborn they'll become
new entities despite this he hopes all
of them will be able to reunite someday
sticking to his ideology to the end
drogo says that cursed spirits are the
true humans when randomly sukuna
abruptly enters the fantasy and asks
jojo if he wants her to become human
sukuna knows jogo means he wants curses
to take the place of humans but believes
this is foolish joko should have burned
everything to a cinder without a second
thought to reach new heights without
ever being concerned about gojo sukuna
believes jogo lacked the hunger to take
a hold of such desires but even so the
battle still entertained him sukuna
admits that compared to everyone else he
has fought over the last millennia jogo
isn't half bad he commends him telling
him to stand proud because he's strong
acknowledged for his strength joko
sheets a tear and asks what's going on
back in reality sukuna answers jojo's
smoldering corpse claiming that he
doesn't know either
immediately after the monk urumay comes
to escort master sukuna which leaves him
surprised as he is someone from the past
elsewhere at 1107 pm exhausted and
injured megami slowly walks away from
his assailant he tells shigemo that the
ten shadows technique begins when the
sorcerer who inherited the technique
receives two divine dogs remember this
battle was going on between shigemo and
megami in order to use other shikigami
they must be summoned and defeated by
the sorcerer with the help of the divine
dogs this allows the user to gain more
shukigami replacing this method until
they can amass up to 10 different ones
uninterested in megami stalling shigemo
asks if this sorcerer is done talking
megami crosses the road away from the
curse user leaving the trail of blood
behind from his injuries shigemo notices
that megami isn't letting him get close
despite being on his last legs even so
shigemo feels like he won't even need to
finish off his adversary moments later
megami collapses and hits the ground
with a hard thund proving this point
megany struggles to get back up but
continues to divulge how his technique
works either way saying that other
people can help with the exorcism ritual
but this will nullify the technique once
it is defeated this makes it a pointless
exorcism but even a pointless exorcism
has its uses gojo sensei explained to
megami why the xenon family and gojo
family are on such bad terms hundreds of
years ago the heads of each household
killed each other in a battle the gojo
family head was a limitless user with
these six eyes and the xenon family head
possessed the ten shadows technique
saturday implied that megami could
possibly rise to his level one day
however in the present megami still
doesn't quite believe he could become
stronger than his mentor so in a moment
of utter despair he decides to use his
last resort as he believes the head of
the household at that time that defeated
these six eyes to use the ten shadows
technique this way as well meanwhile
jogo's maximum measure hits the ground
in the distance getting shigemo's
attention he asks himself who this show
off could be and megami redirects his
attention back to his explanation megami
finishes divulging his technique by
revealing that a 10 shadows technique
user cannot use the shikakukami unless
it has been exercised however they can
be summoned at any time using an
exorcism ritual shigamo turns back
around and notices megami's sudden
influx of cursed energy
due to high student claims that not a
single ten shadows technique user has
ever been able to exercise the shikigami
he is about to bring forth megami
summons the eight-handed sword divergent
silla divine general maharaga dragging
his opponent into an unbeatable exorcism
ritual shigemo realizes the grim
situation he's currently in and megami
who's also on his last legs silently
apologizes to yuji for what he's done
then tells shigemo good luck before
passing on maharaga thumps miguemi aside
sending him into a nearby building and
knocking him out shikuma was shocked by
megami's willingness to sacrifice
himself and curses them for it demanding
the juice who saw sarah get back up and
stop this cruel game
back with sacona after defeating joko
and encountering urumay he feels
something is up and leaves the monk
behind after telling them not to neglect
their preparations sukuna disappears and
the roommate says they'll be awaiting
his return honestly this hero is just
kind of like screaming to me that sekuna
knows something about big brain guido's
plans and he might have even had
something to do with it in the past
overall you know what i mean just before
maharaga crushes shakimo sakuna saves
the cursed user he reads this situation
instantly and recognizes that megami is
in a suspended state of death to prevent
this sukuni uses a reverse curse
technique to heal megami telling him
that there's still something he needs
this student to do shigemo wants to
comment but sukuni tells him to stay
there and stay quiet shakuna surmises
that in order to save megami he needs to
defeat the shikagami sukuna takes his
fighting pose and says he'd like to
begin the battle with just a little
taste maharaga attacks swinging down the
blade attached to its fist sukuno blocks
with his forearm creating a shock wave
that knocked shigemo off balance sukuna
notices that the blade is emitting a
strange energy and gets out of the way
before it breaks through his defense
while in medea sukuna delivers a flurry
of left-handed punches and follows up by
unleashing his curse technique dismantle
which slices the sugar's body all over
while maharaga recovers from the blows
sukuna recognizes the specialized blade
as a curse tool for cursed spirits
called the sword of extermination the
blade is enveloped in positive energy
similar to what's produced by a reverse
curse technique if sukuna was a normal
cursed spirit he would have been sliced
cleaned through the eight-handed wheel
on maharaga's head turns suddenly
healing all of its wounds sukuna quickly
attacks again but this time his slashing
technique is deflected by the shikigami
surprising him maharaga swings its blade
again and sukuna prepares to block but
this time it's immediately broken and
he's sent crashing through several
buildings from the impact amused sukuna
admits that his opponent isn't half bad
in an instant maharaga clears the area
it just hits akuna across to follow up
with another attack it attempts to sub
sukuna in the face but he jumps above
the blade kicking his opponent at the
same time sukuna mounts his giant
opponent's arm and places his right arm
only shukigami's face stating that it's
his turn now skuna activates his
slashing technique slicing the entire
building in half the impact sends the
shikagami falling out of the structure
only for sukuna to follow up and kick it
straight into the ground he lands beside
the sugar and assumes it will heal again
based on his observations the outhanded
wheel turns and all of its injuries
disappear just as expected sukuna
compares this ability to yamato noah
rochi for us webs that want to know is
like a legendary eight-headed and
eight-tailed japanese dragon think like
arochimaru when he comes out of sasuke
and atachi ends up shanking him with a
dopa sword that's kind of like what i'm
thinking here i'm pretty sure it's
taking off that same kind of idea
maharaga's first attack was reinforced
positive energy when that didn't work it
adapted and reinforced its second attack
with cursed energy additionally it was
able to see soconus curse technique and
deflect it both of these things happened
after the eight handled wheel turned for
the first time
photo's incarnation of the 10 sacred
treasures and the eight-handed wheel
represents a complete cycle of harmony
with this information sukuna deduces
that the shikigami's technique allows it
to adapt to any and all phenomena sukuni
admits that if megami had unleashed this
creature when they fought the first time
and may have been able to beat him he
thanks megami for showing him the way
and activates his freaking domain
expansion the insane malevolent shrine
man i honestly just love how much giga
goes into depth on japanese mythology
along with like indian and chinese in
other like six [__] cultures and like
intertwines them all into a story like
it really reminds me of what it felt
like back when i was a little kid to
probably get into a series like bleach
when a roto it's it's just so good i
absolutely love it sukun's technique is
divided into two types of slashing
attacks the default slash dismantle and
the other cleave the latter can be
adjusted using cursed energy to cut down
the target in one foul swoop malevolent
shrine unlike other domain expansions
does not manifest a separate space using
a barrier manifesting one's innate
domain without a barrier is akin to
painting a masterpiece on ear without a
canvas a truly divine and unparalleled
technique by allowing an escape route
from the domain using a binding vowel
sukuna increases the guaranteed hit
accuracy to nearly a 200 meter radius he
narrows down the effective range to 140
meters to avoid hitting megami but
mercilessly slashes the rest of shibuya
apart civilians who are hiding out
nearby after being rescued by any maki
are violently torn to pieces dismantle
is used on inanimate objects while
anything with cursed energy within a
range is hit with cleave while
malevolent shrine is active sucuna's
slashing attacks relentlessly cut down
on everything within its guaranteed hits
effective range with around 150 meters
of shibuya decimated in an instant
zacuna surmises that the only way to
defeat maharaga is to kill it with a new
attack before it can recover however
maharaga has not only adapted to
dismantle but to slashing attacks in
general meaning sukhuna needs to act
quickly he activates his mysterious
flame technique again and shoots a fire
arrow at the sugigami before it heals
the impact creates a giant barrier of
explosive flame that completely
decimates the hellish creature the king
of curses walks back to megami with
maharaga's wheel in hand he throws the
eight-handled wheel past shigemo and it
disintegrates shortly after solidifying
sakuna's victory annoyed sukuna asks
shigimo what he's looking at and tells
him to disappear from sight feeling
extremely lucky shigemo runs off excited
to have escaped another dangerous
situation his innate technique stores
little miracles from every day that are
released to save his life when he's in
danger the markings under his eyes show
how many miracles are stored but he's
not even aware how it works exactly
believing he's escaped through day with
his life shigemo runs off however his
body suddenly sliced apart as he
accidentally runs into sukuna's domain
his body gruesomely falls into two
separate pieces and shigemo finally dies
finally out of like every death that has
happened so far throughout the shibuya
arc this is at least one of the most
freaking deserved deaths dude didn't
realize his luck ran out after nanami
beat his freaking ass anyway anyway
asakuna walks off he can feel himself
finally losing control and decides to
take megumi to where shoko and the
principal are after dropping megami off
sukuni returns to the area in front of
shibuya with his grip over yuji's body
loosening he switches control back over
to the brat and tells him to take a good
look as yuji stands there he's faced
with the wasteland that used to be
doganzaka district shigemo's corpse is
in plain view as the first thing for
yuji to see as well initially
dumbfounded yuji collapses as memories
from sekouna's rampage invade his mind
he vomits and cries after realizing that
sucuna murdered several people including
mimiko nanako and heavily endangering
his friends and colleagues as tears fall
from his eyes and he huffs for air he
tells himself to just die already he
frantically begins scratching around the
ground and continuing to tell himself to
die as his grandfather's words play over
and over in his head
suddenly yunji stops and sits still for
a moment before raising his head and
declaring that he still needs to fight
meanwhile inside shibuya station the
goat nanami despite being severely
injured by dagon's death swarm and
joko's flames is still alive and somehow
walking around with his sword the left
half of his body is completely scorched
including the entire side of his face he
walks past a photo booth while
traversing slowly down the hallway after
nanami passes by mojito sneakily watches
a move through the station until the
sorcerer encounters a large group of
transfigured humans after descending the
stairs and coming face to face with his
swarm the nami begins to daydream about
malaysia he wishes he could have built a
house on a secluded beach and read the
countless books he never got around to
finishing and admits to himself that
he's getting tired yeah i think i think
i'm all about to hurt your souls with
this one here boys nanami asks himself
if he's done enough already but
continues to fight he ferociously slices
through the transfigured humans with his
blunt sword until a familiar hand
touches his chest nanami looks up to see
mojito and claims he didn't know the
curse spirit was around mahita replies
that he's been here the whole time and
asks if the sorcerer would like to chat
since they go way back
instead of replying nanami looks down
and speaks to you he wonders why he came
back to being a sorcerer himself and
asks hayabara what he was trying to do
yuhyubada's spirit appears and points an
army to his right nanami looks over to
find yuji entering the station down the
hall man this is so messed up he tells
hayabara that he doesn't want to end up
cursing the young man so like a damn
king in his last moments nanami smiles
to his protege and tells him that he's
got it from here mohito promptly kills
an army by totally destroying the upper
half of his body shocking the poor yuji
enraged in the next moment yuji rushes
mojito ready to take revenge for his
fallen mentor mahito calmly flicks a
small transfigured human at yuji and
transforms it into one that can produce
spikes from its head yuji avoids the
spike attacks but mojito uses the
transfigured humans to get behind yuchi
and prepare his soul multiplicity
technique he follows up by unleashing
body repel a reaction that's due to the
soul's rejection of the fusion mahito
unleashes a long transfigured human that
attempts to bite yuji with its giant
mouth yuji successfully grips its teeth
and stops the attack but mojito appears
from inside its mouth and lands a
violent right that smashes yuji's face
and splits it open yuji asks how mojito
can toy so aimlessly with people's lives
and the cursed spirit just laughs at him
mojito doesn't look for a reason and he
isn't remorseful in the slightest the
best answer mojito can give is a
demonstration he creates juniper's face
with one hand and stabs it with the
other claiming yuji and him are the same
yuji tells mojito he talks too much and
he will ensure that those are his dying
words he removes the blood from his face
stopping the bleeding and revealing a
large scar nanami's voice reminds yucci
that he must remain calm so as he takes
his fighting stance he allows cursed
energy to flow calmly from his hands as
he's determined to prove that he is a
jejutsu sorcerer mohito matches yuji by
concentrating cursed energy into his own
fists while contemplating his strategy
idol transfiguration doesn't work on
yuji so mojito decides maintaining his
body's toughness is likely what yuji
believes is best for him but instead
mojito won't change his soul's shape at
all and now plans to stab yuji through
his heart in one attack but when his
fist passes through the air yuji
suddenly disappears from his sight using
the momentum from getting to this lower
position yuji then strikes mojito in the
face with the manji kirk yuji then
follows up by front kicking mojito as
well but the curse quickly transforms
his arm into a spiked vine that forces
yuji back impressed mahito admits that
his technique wasn't half bad and
announces that it's time to move on to
round two maheso and yuji continue
fighting in shibuya the cursed spirit
attempts to slash yuji but the latter
jumps over the attack after missing
maheso runs and uses a delayed
transfiguration to catch yuji off guard
he avoids it again and mohito follows up
with a punching attack from a large
enhanced extra arm wrapped around his
torso like he's out of freaking afro
samurai or something with an extra arm
yuji catches the attack and mohito
immediately recognizes the danger this
presents yuji counters but mojito
immediately dismembers his own arm out
of fear he runs through the ticker gate
and merges back with his severed arm
once they're at a safe distance mahisu
knows attacking directly is a big risk
for him so he decides to stick to using
transferred humans however reducing risk
isn't the only reason for the strategy
mohito then runs into a different area
in the station and disappears from
yuji's site the young student gets
spotted by two civilians who warn him
it's dangerous to be lurking around yuji
believes mojito had run upstairs and
tries to tell the two non-sorcerers to
hide suddenly mojito's arm appears from
the inside of their mouths and punches
yuji this special grey climbs out of the
man as if he was shedding his skin and
transforms the other civilian into a
sword honestly man like i forgot about
this part like this is the next level
sneaker it's just pure gangster by
mojito man like turning a person's body
into a sword is so freaking cool anyways
mojito tells his adversary to work on
his imagination
skipping back to nearly two hours ago in
shibuya station around the time mohito
cho so and jogo began their hunt for
yuji in order to find yuji first mojito
had split himself into two presently
mojito's other self encounters nabarra
in an alley way she recognizes him from
past reports from ug hido takes it as a
compliment that he's famous but nibara
claims that he's only known for being a
coward amused mojito decides to kill her
nabarro tries to remember what it was
like to unleash the black flash
attempting to tap into the core of
cursed energy in a short exchange
nabarro manages to get the better of
mojito using clever explosions of her
pins and the environment around them he
admits that she isn't half bad but
doesn't believe her attacks can actually
bring him harm the cursed spirit
understands that nobara is an ally of
yuji's and plans to bring her corpse to
him and destroy his soul so
yeah get ready
at 11 14 pm after nanami left nobara and
akari behind the first year student
refused to leave with the paramedics
team they didn't tell nabarro that shoko
was in the shibuya district so she
didn't do anything reckless however she
ignored nanami's orders to stay out
anyway and went off alone back on the
clock at 11 20 pm inside of this station
mojito skewers three innocent civilians
and uses them to attack yuji as he comes
up the stairs luchi checks on the
conditions of one of the injured people
only for them to transfigure and explode
their blood gets in yuji's eyes leaving
him vulnerable to an attack from behind
mojito transforms his arm into a spike's
club and prepares to finish him off
meanwhile in an alley nearby mohito is
still clashing with nobara she avoids
his hands but mohito's double can't
transfigure other solves anyway this
double attacks by transfiguring himself
since this isn't yuji and he doesn't
incur any risks novara tries to trade
blows but it doesn't seem to work mojito
casually avoids nabara's projectile
nails as she climbs up the side of the
alley onto a higher platform she drops
several nails at mojito's feet and
detonates them with the hairpin before
coming back down confusing mojito with
her movements while he's focused on
herbara she activates hairpin again and
her cursed energy extends them into
mojito's lower body immobilizing him
novara mounts mojito while he's injured
but he doesn't see any potential danger
regardless however unbeknownst to the
special grade nabarro has figured out a
way to attack his soul mojito realizes
nabara was bluffing about not having a
plan but it was too late she hammers a
nail directly into his forehead and
activates resonance by using mahito's
body as the effigy nibara can use her
curse technique to attack his soul as a
result resonance also relays from the
double to the original soul and rebounds
the damage back greatly injuring them
both back in the other fight this injury
just happens to stop him from finishing
yuji off yuji manages to open his eyes
and recognizes nabarro's needle sticking
out of the curse's chest mahiro's double
is shocked and realizes that yuji isn't
his only natural enemy the girl of steel
standing before him can attack his soul
as well
nabarro reveals that she felt her cursed
energy activate somewhere else nearby
additionally she doesn't feel mojito's
curse energy is as strong as it should
be she surmises that mojito is simply a
double that can't properly use his
innate technique amused mojito licks the
blood dripping from his face and admits
his adversary is completely correct
recognizing his classmate's curse
technique yugi capitalizes and pummels
mojito with rapid fire cursed energy
infused punches while yuji bashes mojito
into a pillar with a relentless barrage
he solemnly thanks nabarro yuji believes
he hasn't been able to save anyone and
that he's wasted everyone's efforts but
novara's help has shown him he's still
not alone inspired by nabarro yuji keeps
the pressure on and prepares to exercise
mojito here and now
meanwhile in the alley the nail drops
from mojito's doubles forehead as he
affirms her theory about him nobara
believes the real duel begins now but
the double decides to run away instead
and heads directly into the subway
entrance novara could just ignore him
but she has a bad feeling about letting
him run loose and decides to exercise
him before yuji can finish off mojito's
main body the special grace splits into
several small spherical versions of
himself that run across the room one of
them flares up its cursed energy as they
faint to get yuji's attention and allow
the others to escape the other devils
then reform into mojito's body as he
runs away
both mojitos enter the same corridor
with their 2jiujitsu high students
chasing them yuji initially believes
mojito is trying to heal until he sees
nobara he immediately yells for her to
run away realizing the danger she's
suddenly in since maheso isn't able to
use the idol transfiguration technique
on yuji he made the second body that
can't use idol transfiguration attack
yuji and his other body that can use
idle transfiguration attack nobara as
nobara and mojito fight he was able to
touch her and used his idol
transfiguration nabarro holds her face
and recalls everyone in the village she
was from being crazy she used to believe
that lots of people were crazy and got
in the way of other people's lives but
that was until she attended jiu jitsu
high and learned that being crazy isn't
so bad after all she pictures the images
of all of her friends and apologises to
fomey for being unable to meet her again
in the future nabarro looks at yuji and
tells him to make sure everyone knows it
wasn't so bad and as she says that
nobara's face swells up around her left
eye and bursts from the effects of
mojito's technique
yuji watches in horror as nobara's eye
shoots violently out of her head and her
blood splatters on his face
novara lays before yuji missing an eye
and likely dead
losing to choso sokuna's rampage and
nanami's death had already taken a toll
on yuji's resolve having reached its
limit a long time ago yuji's spirit
breaks after nobara is unable to answer
and he desperately screams her name
this douche happy with himself commends
his own talents and believes he is a
true curse he then successfully
unleashes a damn black flash on yuji
just to follow up on his already dying
soul mojito's black flash sends yuji
crashing through the station this
special grey continues to beat on him
while exposing yuji's determination for
being weak mojito believes that it isn't
simply a battle to fix something this is
a war of truths he believes yuji is the
same as him because he kills without
hesitation just as yuji saves people
without a second thought i truly do love
how well mojito like has been written as
a character like i freaking hate this
guy so damn much like damn damn dude
mohito believes that this conflict will
determine which of the two remains 100
years from now
after thoroughly beating yugi down both
mentally and physically mahito asks this
student how he ever planned on winning
and if he's ever counted how many curses
he's exercised
has never cared about how many people
he's killed and he believes he'll forget
about yuji eventually he morphs his arm
into a praying mantis like claw and
attempts to kill yuji however there is a
clapping noise and suddenly mojito is
displaced you guys know what freaking
time it is right now our boy our brother
toto the eternal brother appears just in
time having used bogie woogie to switch
places with mojito he says that the
prosperous have no choice but to
eventually decline neater also joins the
scene after treating obara toto mostly
tells him to help his brother yuji nix
before telling his nearly defeated
friend that he must wake up
helpless and trembling on the ground in
front of them yuji explains that he
cannot fight anymore not only did nobara
perish in front of his eyes but nanami
was killed by mohito as well to where to
yuji's suffering sucuna slaughtered
potentially dozens of people and yuji
felt he needed to help others to
compensate however he feels he failed
completely crying and withering on the
ground yuji expresses that he simply
can't forgive himself enticed by yuji's
suffering pedo jumps at the group of
sorcerers with his arms shaped into a
thorned like weapon toto claps his hand
and activates boogie woogie to switch
mojito's position in the air with a rata
behind him mohito attempts to turn
around and attack toto but the student
suddenly switches the cursor's position
with yuji taken off guard mojito is left
wide open to a powerful kick that sends
him railing towards errata toto quickly
swaps a writer and mohito again and
takes position in front of his juniors
to face off against his special grade
alone
now what an absolute g man mojito
laughed and admits to himself that toto
is extremely disorientating at the same
time todo tells yuji that he believes as
long as they keep on living those who
have passed on will never truly have
been defeated he adds that looking for
logic and meaning and death can defile
the memories of the dead but todo still
asks yuji for what he's been entrusted
with todo tells yuji that he doesn't
need to answer him right now however
until he does the first year can never
stop fighting he expresses this to yuji
and runs ahead to fight mojito alone
irata quickly treats yuji's injuries by
applying his curse technique he informs
yuji that his injuries won't get any
worse from here on out unless he
sustains new ones arata has already done
the same for nobara he admits that she
didn't have a pulse and isn't breathing
but encourages yuji by adding that there
is a chance of survival arasa then takes
nobara and retreats out of this station
mahito attacks toto and tries to split
himself into a few different ways to
outmaneuver his opponent however toto
proves to be too efficient at avoiding
mojito a small transferred human behind
toto transforms into a large spike by
the third year avoids the attack mojito
is disappointed his opponent didn't even
clap even so he's confident after
tapping into the power of black flash he
believes it's drawing him even closer to
the true essence of his soul toto
suddenly claps and interrupts mojito's
train of thought yuji appears before the
cursed spirit back in the fight he
charges his fist with cursed energy and
reminds himself of nanami's last words
focused and recommitted omni battle yuji
unleashes black flash on mojito
destroying the curse's arm mojito is
knocked back but quickly heals his wound
amused the curse smiles and says that
yuji is back from the dead toto welcomes
him back into the battle as well and
usually stands ready to fight beside him
elsewhere on a train meewa holds one of
mikamaru's communication devices in her
hands she's disappointed as kokichi's
voice informs her that the shibuya
incident will be settled at any moment
now he tells her to turn back because
it's too late but kasumi ignores him and
asks why he only allowed toto and arata
to go kikichi doctored the record so
that everyone else shown the group
including udahime would be away from
shibuya on october the 31st absolutely
lad man kasumi asks if she's useless and
weak since he didn't entrust her and
everyone else to go
she argues that he's the weak one and
admits he made mistakes that he couldn't
even go through with he confesses that
there was someone he loved and believed
they would be fine regardless of the
state of the world as long as they were
together with his time running out
kikichi says his final goodbyes to meewa
as she cries
kikichi asks her to find happiness and
adds that as long as she does that his
wish will have come true for a moment
kikichi appears sitting next to her in
the reflection of the window as he says
his goodbyes his image disappears for
the last time as she looks up into the
window the other members who were left
outside the incident can hear meewah
sadly crying from elsewhere on the train
mai asks udahime about mkhimaru's
betrayal but odahime doesn't believe it
matters since kikichi was killed kamo is
disappointed mikamaru expected so little
from them but momo is simply enraged
that he made her junior cry if only they
understood man what was really going on
meanwhile the battle between mohito and
the juju sorceress rages on with his
fighting spirit reignited yuji fights
effectively alongside toto to keep
mojito on the defensive mojito knows
toto's soul is at full strength and one
transfiguration might not be enough to
kill him yuji's soul is much less stable
but mojito isn't exactly in great shape
either he feels at less than half of his
full strength after having his double
destroyed and being hurt with a black
flash nato plans to deal with toto
switching first and tries to use a
transferred human to distract yuji
however maher was surprised when toto
uses boogie woogie to swap places with
the transfigured human this allows him
to get behind mojito and force the curse
to destroy his own weapon at the same
time toto thinks about feeling like he's
being left behind now that mojito can
use black flash as well yuji refused to
get left behind and use the technique
during the goodwill event todo refuses
to let yuji feel alone and finally like
the big brother he is unleashes his own
black flash pummeling mojito with a
perfect kick nero's arm is broken by
toto's black flash but he still doesn't
believe toda will be able to hurt him
even so this special grade recognises
that all three fighters have reached 120
of their potential mojito then
voluntarily vomits up several miniature
transferred humans and combines them
using soul multiplicity mohito
immediately activates body repel
creating multiple transfigured
snake-like heads that attempt to chomp
at his enemies as the attack breaks
through the underground of shibuya yuji
and toto are forced to move and evade
all of the attacks in the air the latter
recognizes that mahito is countering
boogie woogie by attacking from all
directions meizo empathetically tells
yuji that it's their last chance to
curse one another asking if the curse is
forgotten about him toto swaps all three
of their positions so he's holding the
hato then slams him head first into the
ground yuji attempts to smash mojito's
head with a kick but the curse
dismembers himself to avoid the blow the
special grade's body grows two eyes and
transforms its arm into a blade before
rapidly attacking at the same time
mojito's head grows a separate body and
stands behind his other half to activate
soul multiplicity this time mojito
combined two souls with weak rejection
to form one powerful transfigured human
using polymorphic soul icy mirror toto
uses boogie boogie to continuously give
his side the best spot against the enemy
while believing mohito's body contains
the most of the power but the head
itself is the real hymn because it used
either transfiguration before taking out
mojito's real south turtle attempts to
take out the polymorphic soul isamur
however much to his surprise toto is
suddenly smacked aside with a powerful
blow the impact seen some crashing
through an entire floor and out the
other side into the road but he still
manages to recover his balance the soul
confronts the sorcerer and toto counter
attacks by infusing a rock with cursed
energy and swapping places with it
behind his opponent much to toto's
surprise one hit was enough to kill the
soul icy mirror his surmises that its
explosive power was the result of mojito
expanding numerous souls at once to
manifest it there are two more now
confronting him and todo asks for their
forgiveness before taking each of them
out while mohito was free of boogie
woogie he decided to pile on the attacks
against yuji he uses a more ferocious
version of body repel to attack but the
sorcerer avoids the attack and drop kits
mojito through the air the curse
counters by grabbing yuji's leg and
slamming him onto the ground when the
dust settles from the crash mojito
attempts to follow up the attack however
he's irritated to find the top note goat
standing back at his brother's side
mohito was surprised not even two
polymorphic isomers were enough to stall
or defeat toto he can't transfer toto
without being able to touch him and
sukuni retaliates if mojito attempts a
domain expansion it's too complex for
mojito to exclude yuji from a domain's
barrier so he decides to take
inspiration from the big man himself the
duo are both shocked when mojito
suddenly activates his domain expansion
just like gojo mojito activates his
all-or-nothing domain expansion for 0.2
seconds taking both of his opponents
completely off guard toto acts quickly
and activates a simple domain which he
learned from yuki even faster though is
yuji who's already running towards
mojito in an attempt to exercise them
before either transfiguration can
activate however despite their speed
mojito was the fastest the two-step
process of realizing one's innate domain
and the activation of their curse
technique are combined into one by
mahito who had awakened through black
flash as a result of activating his
domain expansion mohito enters sakuna's
innate domain for a moment he asks
takuna if this is a safe place and
inquires about his agreement with ug the
king of curses remains silent but mohito
continues questioning in order to
challenge sakuna he arrogantly claims
yuji will be dead before zakuna can even
switch places with him and tells the
king of curses to just shut up and watch
the balls on the sky man as the
self-embodiment of perfection ends
toto's left hand begins to transfigure
yuji turns around to check on his
brother but mojito knocks him to the
ground while his back is turned toto
quickly severs his own hand but thus
leaves him vulnerable to the approaching
special grade after activating domain
expansion the user's innate technique
becomes difficult to control mojito
became aware of that fact after escaping
against an army he instead attacks todo
with a strong punch enhanced by black
flash that sends toto into relentless
pain big brain toto though instinctively
concentrated all of his cursed energy to
defend the blow and minimise all of the
damage medo then becomes able to
activate idle transfiguration again and
plans to kill toto with the next hurts
nato's focus though is suddenly
interrupted when toto's necklace falls
onto the ground and knocks open a small
picture frame containing the photos of
yuji and takada while his opponent is
distracted yuji uses mojito's hand to
clap and activate boogie woogie toto
instantly switches places with yuji who
strikes mihito in the face with another
black flash toto collapses and looks at
his remaining hand while expressing that
he's lucky to be alive ready to finish
the fight alone now yuji looks back at
toto and thanks him for all of his help
final battle shibuya finally begins or
is it the final battle i guess we'll
find out
i guess we'll find out next
heavily injured mohito creates a
polymorphic isomer to hold yuji off he
admits toto was a problem for him till
the very end but despite his depleting
condition mohito believes he's found the
true essence of his soul yuji defeats
the polymorphic isomer and as this
happens medium evolves into the final
stage of his being emerging from a
cocoon of probably cursed stuff you know
who knows what it is he then instantly
activates idol transfiguration on
himself making himself into an instant
spirit body of distorted killing this
form is just like super clean man like i
said it's probably one of giga's out of
this world type [__] not just a normal
like anime character face i love it like
made up that's probably why i like it in
the midst of these cities ruins yuji
glares at his greatest enemy and wonders
what his newest transfiguration brings
the cursed spirit feels reborn and asks
yuji to wish him a happy birthday to
celebrate the momental occasion having
unleashed black flash mojito believes he
has tapped into his true unbridled soul
yuji didn't take his adversary to be won
for a self-discovery journey amused
maher replies that only after killing
yuji does the cursed spirit feel that he
can truly be reborn the two fighters
instantly blitz one another to reignite
their battle nihiro makes the first move
creating a shock wave with just a wave
of his arm yuji ducks under the wave and
attacks with a straight kick that's
caught by the black heads protruding
from mojito's head the curse tries to
take the advantage with a tail whip but
yuji blocks it he is then able to parry
mojito's punch and counter with an
uppercut to his body however yuji's
cursed energy infused punch deals
absolutely no damage at all mahiru
knocks yuji away and forces him to
realise that the curse spirit
transcended way beyond his former state
they trade blows but yuji's attacks are
unable to reach his opponent any longer
yuji is overwhelmed and slammed into the
street creating a giant crater from the
impact the street crumbles apart and
yuji falls down to the bottom as water
fills the bottom of the crater where
yuji now stands across from mojito the
former realises he can only win using a
black flash infused punch with maximum
cursed energy mohito attempts to take
advantage of yuji's small laps by
rushing in however the curse spirit
immediately stops their tendrils on the
back of his elbows partially
disintegrate and mojito even coughs up
blood getting hit by black flash so soon
after deactivating domain expansion
seriously injured mojito amused with
their final standoff mojito wipes the
blood from his mouth and states both of
them have plenty left in the tank mojito
rushes his opponent creating a giant
splash and the water from his incredibly
fast movements yuji immediately clenches
his fist in his palm and charges all of
his cursed energy into it mahiru
attempts to attack yuji from behind but
the sorcerer ducks under in time the
curse spirit then tries to come adam
with a right hook but yuji uses the back
of his palm to parry it having been hit
a bunch now maydo knows that he's
vulnerable to being hit by another one
of yuji's black flash attacks meaning
going in recklessly will only lead to
his end but leaving here's a
countermeasure in mind mojito partially
deactivates his distorted killing form
on the left side of his body this
special grade believes yusu will aim at
his sweet spot and that will lead to the
chance to counter and decapitate him
yuji indeed does strike a mojito's left
side appearing to take debate but just
as mahiru goes for the kill a second
impact throws the trajectory of the
strike off juji ducks unimahido's missed
attack and prepares to deliver the final
blow
the curse spirit reinforces the left
side with his instant spirit body of
distorted killing and tries to hit his
opponent first
suddenly though al go the broski the bro
the brother toto's voice echoes through
the battlefield interrupting mojito's
momentum toto tells the cursed spirit
that an arm is simply a declaration and
an act of applause is an acclamation of
one's soul time this man is a poet man
besto frendo uses his freaking amputated
hand to imitate clapping with his
remaining hand trying to anticipate the
switch mohito quickly turns around and
attacks he ends up hitting nothing
though and realizes that he's been
utterly fooled by toto one last time
toto apologizes and claims that bogie
woogie is already dead yuji takes
advantage of his ally's clever thinking
and strikes mojito with a black flash
imbued with maximum cursed energy the
impact from yuji's blow is so fierce it
coats his opponent in a streak of cursed
energy that blasts the cursed spirit
completely out of the crater mohito is
heavily injured and forced out of his
distorted killing form additionally this
special grade is out of transfigure
humans as desperation sets infamhito for
the first time in his existence guji
stands over him just as the curse
proclaimed earlier in the fight yuji
admits that he is mojito he no longer
requires a reason to kill him and will
exercise curses no matter what form they
take fully aware now that is nothing but
a cog and they struggle between two
sides yuji is confident to play his role
as a jutsu sorcerer against the threat
of cursed spirits nato desperately tries
to flee as yuji chases from behind like
a wolf chasing the rabbit through the
snow like oh dude when this when this
was going down with the first time i was
freaking screaming and chanting like oh
my god man
i can't actually like the pages were on
fire like full on they weren't like
seriously
oh my god before yuji can finish my
hazel off someone appears ghetto
suddenly appears before mahito standing
over him and looking down on his fellow
special grade flashing away at 10 36 p.m
in kuala lumpur malaysia which you know
obviously is a big shout out to our boy
nanami and obviously this is like where
they were going to escape to after if
things went bad i think anyway maymay
teased wee-wee about sharing their bed
until someone gave her a call back she
revealed to that person that she was
nearly killed by gesso and had to escape
using wee-wee's technique she advises
them to sell all of the japanese stock
and tokyo real estate immediately having
also already exchanged her yen maima
expects a possible negative chain
reaction could still affect other nearby
developed nations japan's economy is the
third largest in the world and could be
in for a major decline around the same
time panda located kusaka bay choso was
continuing to have flashbacks of yuji in
his life alongside his brothers after
shooting the tear for his brothers
chosen decided he needed to move unsure
of himself now chosun needs to know what
yuji is
at 11 36 p.m ghetto asks mojito if he is
in need of saving yuji acts quickly
recognizing ghetto's name and appearance
he demands gojo back and rushes towards
the curse user getting nonchalantly
though explains that people of the
mid-edo period spoke of a mysterious
connection between catfish and
earthquakes at the same time he summons
a small catfish curse spirit that swims
into the underground suddenly a gigantic
hole created by the curse appears
underneath eugene the first year loses
his balance and appears to fall into the
hole however yuji abruptly falls onto
the ground as if the hole never even
existed completely dazing him ghetto
asks if yuji believed he had fallen and
says from a side view it just looked
like he suddenly flipped over he
explains the strengths of cursed spirit
manipulation lies in the higher number
of moves at the user's disposal by
wielding multiple curse spirits of semi
grade 1 and higher ghetto can unleash
different types of attacks every time
his opponent adjusts ghetto demonstrates
this using a curse that takes the form
of a swarm of centipedes crawling out of
a black webbing to ensnare euge then the
catfish curse opens another hole at the
same time suspending yuji in the air
without any balance before stacking
another centipede attack and smashing
the sorcerer into the ground as yuji
lays on his hands and knees bloodied
from the attack ghetto realizes that the
first year had nothing to do with the
events a year earlier instead luji
simply demands satoru back and ghetto
laughs in response while admitting that
tikun's vessel is tough maheru attempts
to hit ghetto from behind but his hand
is easily avoided the cursed brit admits
he knew yuji was tough all along since
he was born from humans ghetto then
absorbs mojito as the cursed spirit
utters his final words standing before
yuji holding mojito sealed inside a
black orb ghetto begins to explain
maximum techniques they are innate
techniques most powerful art outside of
a domain expansion cursor manipulation
maximum uzumaki combines the cursed
spirits and the user's possession to
unleash a burst of super condensed
cursed energy randomly ghetto begins to
laugh yuji asks what's so funny and the
curse user replies that he accidentally
started acting like suguru continuing on
about uzumaki he explains the technique
is powerful but he initially believed
and negated the great number of moves at
the cursed manipulator's disposal guido
admits he was wrong about uzumaki
because when semi-grade 1 and high curse
spirits are utilized their curse
technique is extracted pretty much what
he means is he's able to use any curse
technique from a semi-grade one or
higher and still use maximum material
using all of the other curses that
remain as well plus probably some of the
power from that curse i would imagine
but he won't lose like that ability of
like idle transfiguration or like say
any other ability that he might get in
the past ghetto swallows the black orb
containing a hexo officially adding the
special gray to his collection while
looking up gideo tells yuji it's foolish
to think he wouldn't notice momo is
floating above him on her broom using
the lantern as a signal for her allies
to attack from long range kamo is the
first to act firing cursed
energy-infused arrows at the enemy
ghetto avoids the arrows but immediately
notices a speeding bullet coming
directly at him however he simply blocks
mai's bullets with a curse as meewa
joins the fight she recalls her past and
how she met her mentor in junior high
deciding to become a to sorcerer despite
having never even held a wooden sword
meewa quickly slides in behind ghetto
and activates new shadow style while
recalling her blistered and bloodied
hands maybe who puts everything into the
swing she's prepared to never even use
their sword again and attacks with
battle sword drawing however gito simply
catches the blade with his bare hands
and shatters it immediately after
negating miiwa's attack guido activates
maximum uzumaki with the technique
having been divulged yuji knows about
uzamaki's power and yells for the curse
user to stop momo usually looks down and
moves to save miwa but sadly uzumaki
destroys the ground with a blast of
super condensed cursed energy leaving a
gaping hole in the ground from the
impact however the technique didn't
actually hit anyone and ghetto admits
that it's nice facing someone with
experience rather than these students
kugosabe was able to use his new shadow
style to cancel out part of the curse
technique and protect maewa at the same
time panda arrives to the battlefield
and checks on yuji he's relieved to see
that yuji is back in control of his body
he asks if the cursed user has the
cursed object holding saturday gojo
camus asks who the curse user is and
panda can only say that it's a
mysterious person that has assumed the
identity of tsukuru ghetto by
controlling his body suddenly our boy
the other brother chosu arrives on the
battlefield surprising yuji ghetto
welcomes him but our boy in the middle
of his like i don't even know if you can
call this a mid-life crisis or curse
crisis you guys choose what one he
completely is he's a mix in my mind
still finally recognizes the curse user
as one of his three parents
so yeah this is kind of messed up right
man like for real there is uh choices
mother the curse spirit who got her
pregnant which is freaking weird man and
the man who tore me to chose his mother
to create the cursed womb death
paintings chozo hated this person and
now that person is inhabiting sukuru's
body
this thing is no one other than the most
evilest sorcerer in history the prolific
noritoshi kmo
obviously this is kind of uh confusing
for those that are sitting there like yo
wait you say naruto shikemo that's that
other dude like it even it even confuses
the students here so i don't blame you
pretty much this dude's just old ass man
like just think of it he's oh he's from
the past he's an old camo udahime clears
it up more that chozo is referring to
the stain of the kamo clan kuzukabe
believes that it makes sense for him to
be someone with absurd barrier
techniques cursed objects and the
ability to switch bodies ghetto claims
that naratoshi kamo is just one of the
many names he's gone by so possibly the
dude could have even been like far older
than we even suspect at the moment
because we don't know where he started
you know where did the brain dude start
from jose rushes at narutoshi however a
roommate abruptly cuts him off sliding
next to ghetto and telling the bottom
feeder to step aside ruff arumi tells
cho so not to make them wait any longer
but chozu replies for the curse user to
get out of his way and repeat that he's
yuji's older brother so yeah it's a
finally explained here why he thinks
that a side effect of chosen's curse
technique is that he can sense the
transformation of his younger brothers
through their blood connection just
before finishing off yuji in their fight
earlier in shibuya choso could feel the
sensation of death coming from yuchi
just like he did with his other brothers
tachoso this can only mean that yuji is
also his younger brother by the way i'm
just calling brain dude brain dude or
brain or narutoshi until we know his
name i'm not going to call him kamo i'll
just call kamokamo so it doesn't get
confusing yeah narutoshi has extended
his life from moving from host to host
making it possible that yuji and choso
could share some sort of blood relation
in order to fulfill his duty as an older
brother chosu was ready to protect yuji
with all his strength chosu activates
blood manipulation convergence
surprising kamo with how superior it is
to his own
chosu fires piercing blood and it almost
reaches arumi's face in the blink of an
eye the monk is surprised by the immense
speed of piercing blood and barely
manages to stop hurt ghetto sidesteps
the attack while it draws a hole through
one of his partner's cursed energy
reinforced hands chozo swings the stream
of blood sending the arrow back to slash
at naratoshi this breaks up the ground
and chozo uses the blood he placed there
to disrupt ghetto's footing they then
engage each other by trading blows in
close quarters naratoshi is the first to
land a significant strike and suggests
chozo shouldn't strain himself after
fighting so much earlier on jose doesn't
believe being tired is any excuse to
stop putting his life on their line to
protect his younger brother confused
panda asks if yuji is really related to
joso yuji doesn't believe they were
related at all and reveals how chozo had
nearly even killed him earlier which is
you know like what the [__] man
regardless of his relationship with yuji
norotoshi points out that choso is
creating a disturbance that they need to
take advantage of with two cores still
going strong panda goes out in full
gorilla mode while the others follow
behind him he activates his unblockable
drumming beat but suddenly a roommate
activates their innate technique ice
formation urumay uses frost khan to
release an icy mist that freezes cho so
narutoshi panda and kusakabe ghetto asks
them not to kill these sorcerers because
he needs messengers and a roommate heals
his hand using a reversed curse
technique discouraging kusakabe who
considers these curse users to be on a
whole other level chosu activates
flowing red scale to rapidly increase
his body's temperature and melt the ice
a roommate appears in front of cho so
but yuji one of the only ones who wasn't
frozen dropped kicks choso out of the
ice to save him from a roommate annoyed
the monk asks who does the vessel think
that body belongs to yuji believes that
he wasn't frozen judas akuna and asks
cho so what side he's on chozu denies
he's fighting with the sorcerers and
states once again he's yuji's older
brother he even asks yuji to try calling
him big brother just once which reminds
me i obviously have toto so hard man
yuji ignores this because he notices
momo flying down towards the group on
her broom momo uses her wind scythe to
launch a blade of cursed energy from her
broom at the two cursed users a roommate
is able to block this attack with their
bare hands frustrating momo with yuji
momo and cho so the only one still
mobile the kyoto student tells the other
two that they need to buy time for
utahime dissatisfied with needing a
messenger as a reason for keeping this
many sorcerers alive aruma activates ice
formation they claim yuji alone will be
enough and creates a steam of icicles
that surrounds both curse users and
splits apart to freeze them the flying
ice bits attack and freeze yuji choso
and momo in place a second wave of
sharpened icicles attacked them from
above pretty much cementing their deaths
until a mysterious shikagami suddenly
appears to break the ice apart the
special grade sorcerer yuki appears on
the battlefield she asks ghetto the same
question again from all those years ago
inquiring as to what kind of girls he's
into so you know like if you're
wondering who toto's taught by it's yuki
it's this chick here the special great
sorcery yuki the third one that we
haven't actually properly met the two
sorcerer's clash philosophies regarding
the future of humanity's relationship
with cursed energy yuki believes humans
need to break away from curse energy
while guitar believes optimizing it will
bring about the evolution however the
world ghetto pursues would be full of
bloodshed because japan has a virtual
monopoly on cursed energy something like
that would cause the other world powers
to retaliate and use humans as an energy
source girl doesn't care if the world
ends up that way he believes there is
more to the human potential beyond
sorcerers and cursed spirits he
attempted to create the death paintings
to bring that potential into existence
however ghetto has deemed that a failure
and has since realized that anything he
can create on his own does not exceed
the abound of his own personal potential
the answer he seeks is hidden within the
darkness and only the chaos that
naratoshi can't even control can bring
it forth he reveals that he's already
extracted the curse technique he needs
to begin this process yuki has a
realization and asks what happened to
mojito prompting yuji to reveal that
ghetto had just absorbed him the curse
user remotely activates idol
transfiguration on every human he's
marked he thanks yuji for bringing out
mojito's full potential because his
cursed energy stopped improving the
moment it was absorbed the two types of
non-sorceries have been marked prior to
the remote casting of idol
transfiguration the first type are
non-sorcerers who are meant to stay as
such but instead have awakened new curse
techniques much like juniper this second
are vessels that ingested cursed objects
like ug ghetto's plan is to release a
thousand malevolent sorcerers and get
them to fight one another yuki doesn't
believe a thousand rational people would
fight one another to death but it was
sure to her he wouldn't make any over
sights annoyed yuki asks yuji to help
her beat up the imposter yuji can't move
though due to the ice holding him but
chozu's poisonous blood abruptly causes
a roommate to collapse down onto one
knee and the ice suddenly starts melting
before they move though guido declares
the cursed objects he provided were
created from these sorcerers he made
vows with a millennia ago however those
vows became null when he obtained
sukhodogiro's body yuki understands the
implications of this just as noratoshi
announces that this is the world of the
future he shows the prison realm to his
enemies and bids farewell to yuji
claiming to expect a lot from him in the
coming times the young man calls out
gojo's name one last time and ghetto or
no ratoshi or brain or whatever finally
addresses sukuna directly he tells the
king of curses that an era reflecting
the he and era is coming and that the
golden age of jiu-jitsu is returning
so that officially brings us to the very
end of what is jutsu kaizen shibuya
incident arc and obviously this freaking
arc here is actually insane the stuff
that goes down throughout this arc like
the fights between toji and megami and
obviously toji and dagon and the group
there and they're like individual
fighting needs to gone and then the
stuff that happens with freaking
saturday at the beginning of the arc
with him getting sealed is obviously
like the main big thing with this arc
and then right at the end of it with
freaking
freaking sugar ghetto finally announcing
his plan to everyone which is actually
you know like coming to come to be i
guess you could say as that is the
result of what is going on right now and
the culling game so obviously i'm going
to move into those up and coming arcs in
the next few videos because i definitely
want to cover more of jiu-jitsu kaizen i
am a little bit behind where the story
currently is but i'm kind of caught up i
kind of know what's going on at the
moment so i'm super excited to be able
to actually cover that in this you know
kind of video format that i've been
doing obviously if you guys did enjoy
you know this kind of video and want to
see more stuff just like it where i go
over other stories or other arts from
different animes and mangas then make
sure you hit that subscribe button and
also be sure to leave a like on the
video and if you want to see more stuff
you know like this but just a fraction
of a time slightly earlier then make
sure to check out my patreon down in the
description below where you can get like
i guess little tidbits and uh updates
occasionally of what i'm kind of up to
and if you if you just want to like
follow me and see what i'm up to more
frequently and you know let's see all
the manga that i buy and what i get up
to on the weekends then make sure you
check out my twitter which i will leave
obviously down in the description below
as well or here somewhere on screen
obviously i can't thank you all enough
for the support that i've been getting
with my chainsaw man video uh like the
full story that i uploaded it's been
exploding before the freaking trailer is
even released which is actually mental
to me i can't like i can't actually
believe how many people have got into
the series before the freaking trailers
even come out or before the animes had
like any solid trailer actually come out
we've only had that first one and it's
not really like giving us too much of a
look into what's actually there there's
just a lot of explosions like
and only if you've read the story you
kind of know what's to come and what's
about to hit like happen from those
little scenes and so i'm super excited
to see you know what this final trailer
brings us and i'm pretty sure it's on
the seventh so in like six or five days
from now it'll be out yeah anyway
obviously enough of that that's gonna be
old by the time this video is two months
old yeah anyway i'll catch you all in a
bit for now it's been a professional
degenerate diavolo and i'll see you
later bye